je crois que je suis bon du coup je vais
recadrer les calmes mvl la cam de max
c'est le sait pas celle là c'est celle
là la cam de max il est pas encore là
mais il va être là et la cam de l'even
c'est celle là donc on va pouvoir lever
notre verre voilà il est là les bonnes
ok on a les calmes
il nous manque le bas qui il nous manque
le bas qui on est bon les gars pour ce
match extraordinaire je mets le petit
polo sur maxime prend les gars là je
suis en train je vous n'imaginez pas
quelle vitesse je fais tout ça et je
vais essayer de récupérer qui j'enlève
mes écouteurs et j'en vois un gars qui
j'ai enlevé
j'ai enlevé le son comme ça vous prenez
pas le truc désagréable et sa part
salut baky série kevin la forme ça va ça
va ok tu as déjà le nom de revenir ah
bah oui oui je suis un génie je suis
rapide à attend il ne propose pas le bon
partage d'écran atteint 2,91 bien alors
attendez perdu du temps avec tour live
et domingo ah bah oui mais c'était beau
laima le petit gambie roi ouais bon
maxime déjà magnifique on est très très
bien après j'ai hésité tu vois à lui
faire des ouvertures je vais faire les
petits et les petits tableaux de match
j'ai pensé que c'était bien j'ai hésité
le cavalier d2 d'un proche d'eux c'était
sympa non je pense bête a trouvé un peu
dur à je sens que tu as trouvé que
c'était un peu dur non ça va c'était
cool le damage code d'un proche de maths
j'étais là pour ça pas tout trouvé c'est
du taxi coreca nous c'est du power of
tactique que j'ai fait c'est du power
tech keklah power technique c'est un peu
plus dur mais bon d'un autre côté ils
allaient vallotton jeu mais je suis venu
aussi parce que on m'a prévenu qu'il y
avait la petite
il y avait la petite qui montre à quel
est hâtive et bien du coup c'est déjà
parti le match avec maxime qui envoie
une italienne mais ils partent à l'heure
ça faire alors aujourd'hui hockey allawi
c'est ouais mais là il ya tout tout
s'enchaîne magnifique à la tétée malin
c'est pas bien mais ça va ça un petit
italienne qui part comme je connais pas
italienne gianni vue il a déjà joué
maxime et l'italienne a je crois pas
c'est la première surtout cette variante
là je crois que j'ai vraiment jamais vu
jouer c'est sûr at ans sa dernière
partie oui quand les quarts où il a joué
quelques quelques il en a joué quand
même je crois
après celle ci s'était et alien ou s'il
avait bien sûr tahita les petits murs de
beaucaire faith non mais là quelle à
sourire c
c'est la même que contre hikaru no non
pas exactement la même ya pas eu d âge
c'est ce qu'affirme d'accord est-ce que
tu l'as vence forme hier sur le road
alors je fais en pleine bourre j'ai
regardé quelques parties et je suis
arrivé quand il a perdu parce qu'avant
je t'assure pas rater avant il jouait
moi j'ai trouvé qu'il jouait vraiment
bien il voyait beaucoup pour ces deux
premières j'ai vu les deux premières
d'un oeil un peu distrait quand même
mais il était je crois qu'elle était
vraiment bien les deux premières et
après j'arrive il y avait huit et demi
un ennemi contre collard ce qui est pas
mal ce qui est plutôt bien parce que
c'est un bon voire collard cela il était
complètement complètement gagnant il a
perdu il a voulu faire le beller de
gestion h2 il y avait une peau de pions
d'avancé le petit pion h 2 mais c'est
quoi il fait d'albé but c'est n'importe
quoi au nom d'un débit de tabac s'être
tu te jure que je crois que j'ai déjà vu
ça avec vlad même et tu connais pas il a
joué il a joué contre hikaru s'est elle
ainsi c'est là une ancienne ligne que
les carouges jouer changé avec ce petit
h 6 e cavaliers au 7 mai jouer au hockey
c'est en vrai c'est la ligne de ding
ding v8 damas est vraiment à l'origine
quoi c'était la ligne 2 ging qui a été
reprise par hikaru hikaru a arrêté pour
certaines raisons j'imagine hélas là les
veines le jour elles ont que nous ne
connaissons évidemment pas non mais
c'est aussi évidemment la partie de
maxime contre mamediarov ouais mais au
grand prix fina à riga là c'est ça c'est
ça ou maxi maroc ram ainsi c'est le
genre de position que maxime aime bien
après après les bonnes joues julie la
jouer plus vite que maxime finalement
ceux de lorelei voilà c'est bizarre là
tout ce qui s'est passé
maxime nous a dit que c'était souvent
des matchs serrés entre les bonnes et
lui ouais je sais pas pourquoi je pense
qu'il le respecte un petit peu trop
c'est pour ça que on sera pas la
dernière coupe du monde qu'ils avaient
éliminé ces temps
en huitièmes ou en car c'est dans une
position maxime était perdant et où les
vonn avait avait craqué d'accord tu
parles de celle là oui je parle de celle
où j'étais avec maxime ans de
l'armageddon là qu'il envoie pas au
candidat en 2017
oui on a complètement dominé et c'était
vraiment incroyable de pub c'est marrant
parce qu'il s'est pas qualifié sur le
match qu'il a dominée et il a gagné
celui où ils étaient dominés entre qui
sait ça alors pour le coup il ya la
coupe du monde dans ce match était
vraiment dominé mais bon il était hyper
fatigué ça faisait déjà six mois qu'il
était sur la route
oui ce qu'il avait envoyé jusqu'en 2000
contre raj à bafou il avait il avait
perdu la partie conseil venait le match
contre à jabba le match contre les boks
que celui avant avant radjabov comment
voit il avait fait sûrement ce vide
l'air en huitièmes les vannes en l'air
en gare ouais il a les langues mais bon
ils étaient bloquées six effet dominé
par les bonnes on peut avant de perdre
contre raj à ceux qui l'étaient déjà
vraiment crevé que parce que maintenant
il joue quand même beaucoup mieux que
que les vols il jouait c'est quelqu'un
de mon âge qui a même plus que moi il
est plus âgé que toi lemon way bois pas
beaucoup parce qu'on attend jouent
ensemble déjà championne du monde des
moins de 12 ans moins de dix noms parce
qu'ils n'auront plus que moi en fait
6 - 10 on avait joué d'ailleurs on la
joue 1,92
on n'a pas joué mais il a fini derrière
gris choquée moi et mon 92 duisbourg
comment tu expliques tu cette longévité
côté arménien parce que c'est l'avenir
dans quelques jours une tag radio si
riche ou gris choco s'il reste au top
niveau
c'est vrai tu as quelques joueurs comme
ponomariov moi bon et bien descendu mais
après il faut toi faut le pouvoir faut
le vouloir enfin bon mais qu'est ce qui
fait la différence à un moment donné de
vouloir se maintenir longtemps ou parce
que tu as des joueurs comme toi qui qui
se maintient bien va je veux pas dire
que je me retiens pas tes 50 m'engage
c'est déjà bien je sais juste pas non
mais tu te maintien très très très bien
mais génère qu'est ce qui fait que
certains joueurs comme
non deux comme les vannes comme bas
c'est en fait ça dépend ce que tu fais
si tu fais que des échecs non stop
ok tu vas me laisser jouer faire 10 de
penser dix heures par jour et chaque
évidemment je vais revenir top 15 tomes
voir mes sens donc il avant la volonté
quoi la suite top 50 top 60 ans j'ai
combien d'heures d'échec par par semaine
je sais pas très peu ce que tu peux pas
compter ce que je fais pour ma tin oui
c'est vraiment très spécifiques et c'est
vraiment pour lui donc ça ne sert
quasiment pas limite ça me sert plus
quand je lui ai regardé trucs pour des
rapides ou des blitz parce que je peux
les utiliser mais j'ai très vite
vraiment ce que je vois un chien quand
je joue pas là depuis je peux donc je
peux me j'ai pas joué de mars à début
septembre
donc j'ai joué en septembre douze
parties mais de mars à début septembre
on va dire pour moi j'ai utilisé
peut-être sous pas en moyenne une heure
par semaine je sois pas à me comparer
avec avec les vannes qui j'imagine
qu'ils utilisent beaucoup plus avec des
gens qui travaillent pour lui encore
voit donc c'est vraiment une question de
choix de carrière choix de vie c'est une
décision personnelle quoi ouais après
c'est plus simple d'être dix ans c'est
plus sympa quand même de passer tout ce
temps et où quand et top 10 parce que là
tu peux investir de l'argent du temps
après et quand tu es déjà top 15 ça va
c'est déjà plus dur tu vas passer la
presse au fouquet's on joue pour le
plaisir bien sûr mais moi je peux pas me
permettre
tu vois de jouer que bon plaisir donc
mais je comprends les joueurs s'étaient
c'était intéressant de te poser la
question et entendre hideux tentant dé
répondre quoi parce que c'est une
question que les gens se posent
probablement tu vois c'est pour ça que
c'est le temps que tu passes ouais ouais
donc soit apte à décider au lieu jeu si
tu veux si tu veux me dédoubler d'accord
je vais travailler pour une fois est ok
je serai bien sûr pas aussi fort que
maxime c'est pas la question mais
évidemment je serai au top donc vain un
moment donné tu fais un choix de
carrière de te dire tu préfères être
l'entraîneur du champion du monde
potentiellement que des toilettes top 15
corps mais après c'est pas facile de
tramway mais c'est aussi ok il faut le
vouloir quoi de travailler six sept
heures par jour
deux femmes étudiées fait ses classes à
son quoi tu fais pour maxime au final de
bosser cinq six heures par jour
d'accord mais oui mais c'est pas pareil
je ne sais pas je sais pas comment
expliquer non parce que c'est aussi
stressant quand aujourd hui non mais
c'est super c'est hyper complexe mais
c'est complexe non mais ça intéresse
assez intéressant c'est intéressant
parce que tu vois c'est un monde quand
même assez élitiste entre guillemets il
n'ya pas tu as et un c'est intéressant
quand on a envie d'un peu rentré dans
l'est dans les coulisses coop
oui bah du coup il en parlant de nom
mais c'est en entrée la de façon on a le
temps c'est ça permet je sais je sais on
attend non mais oui il faut voilà faut
avoir du temps faut le vouloir
par ailleurs un sport de haut niveau tu
vas tu as plein de joueurs de foot en a
qui arrêtent à trente deux ans ne s'est
pas accentuée de ses 40
je vais c'est que la marge du sexe ça le
fait chier de en fait ça l'intéresse
plus d'entraîner un champion du champion
du monde que d'être que d'être top 15
top 20 par exemple blague
en fait c'est pas facile d'accepter le
fait que en travaillant un axe ton max
il sera moins haut que il ya cinq ans ou
dix ans
c'est exactement ce qu'ils disent et
vlad une fois que tu la touche et on max
tu dis tu peux plus jouer si bien ok
après ça tu choques enfin je veux dire
tu fais une erreur en tentant alors que
tu as imagine tu passes 50 je passe 50
heures par semaine et je passe deux
mille heures par an faire que des échecs
et j'arrive pas à monter top 15 au top
20 à cause d'une partie vraiment débile
toi mais alors que un truc il ya dix ans
a passé jamais enfin je ne sais jamais
passé c'est cette impression de 2,2 de
jouer de ne plus pouvoir donner son
maximum et donc de plus vouloir faire
les efforts pour
non mais tu peux les faire en général tu
peux en faire quand même mais pas
vraiment c'est différent tu penses qu'un
joueur comme les vannes il a encore des
espoirs de titre de champion du monde ou
quoi ou en lui même je veux dire c'est
tellement plaisant qu'elle est bonne il
a gagné il a déjà gagné toute sa vie et
fait pile a pas envie de faire autre
chose et mais par contre oui il accepte
le fait de voilà qu'ils fassent ce
qu'ils travaillent qu'ils fassent le mas
est d'être un numéro je sais pas combien
ils avaient numéro 10 où bon il est si
cela jette un oeil les six ok là il est
vraiment au max de chez max quoi pour
maintenant mais on fait d'accepter quoi
et c'était clairement le numéro deux
mondial pendant longtemps qu'eux mêmes
oui bien sûr là par exemple cram dit
qu'il n'a pas accepté donc il arrêtait
tout simplement kasparov la même chose
karpov il a accepté et il joue encore
maintenant fin manon met d'accord mais
tu vois c'est intéressant mais chacun
enfin chacun son truc donc là bas c'est
game non ses pions et puis on est temps
magnifique
ça a l'air d'être plus en étant ça a
l'air d'être gagnée tienne il est fort
hein déjà il ya celtie rod et or qui lui
a bien servir maxime wade comme s'ils
avaient vraiment l'air d'être en forme
c'était très rassurant pour aujourd'hui
wen clients au-delà du fait d'être en
forme hier c'est que ça me met en forme
pour aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est
important
ben écoute j'ai l'impression qu'ils
jouent vraiment mieux sur internet par
il ya eu un déclic à quelque chose qui
s'est passé ouais ouais bah je sais pas
comme on disait c'est peut-être leur de
lors des parties tout simplement
ouais ça joue peut-être vie peut-être
aussi le fait que quand c'est sa petite
sa petite balade au pakistan ça c'était
peut-être bénéfique
ça fait du mira res qui calcule pas et
calcule tarifs 5 et 6 qui est français
huit as et s arrête
ouais c'est sûr qu'à et des quatre
cavaliers à cette web et voilà c'est
fini car il sait bien c'est pas mal ce
qu'il a fait parce que ouais jusqu'à la
lie à ces trois c'est sète hérault avait
6 après il peut récupérer ce pion et ça
et ça arrive et 3,6 il va falloir les
gagner
bon je vienne y en a ou pas non c'est
nul mais j'ai
j'ai perdu cette position partie longue
contre contre nice si je dis pas de
bêtises ou un bon un joueur fort joueur
à 2006 il ya il ya une quinzaine
d'années et donc c'est pas un coeur
rempli de ça avec quelques secondes à la
pendule voilà qu'elle g5 se trouve que
c'est gagnant ou pas oui ça ressemble la
gare 6 3 et 6 nuls non j'ai pas choisi
trois gagné autant tu peux pas le
contourner
ah non est-ce qu'il veut gagner autant
il nous a dit que ça va ressembler à
trois fois la même position c'est
l'horreur ouais mais bon c'est bon
augure que même pour la suite il pouvait
passer leurs liens avec le roi parce que
les tirs venaient prendre le pion alors
il se défend corps et âme avec peu de
temps les bonnes
c'est ce que je disais à maxime hier que
c'est bizarre c'est vraiment un truc qui
doit perdre en ligne en fait
enfin qu'il doit perdre j'aime pas 99
sur 100 il doit perdre mais tu sais que
contre n'est pas déjà il a été très
impressionnant quand il avait peu de
temps plein de fois je commente avec
sami robin on a pensé qu'il était mal
autant dans des positions un peu comme
ça un peu complexe tu vois à défendre
bon tu dérailles beaucoup de temps mais
qui sont complexes avec peu de temps et
il en a défendu mais je sais pas combien
c'était impressionnant
ouais mais bon après maxime il va pas
laisser passer à chaque fois non plus la
prochaine fois il fait un peu plus
attention je pense en début de finale
oui bien sûr at heart velder qui se
présente quand même jacques hérisset
temps 98 contracte de shine voilà
c'était ya 22 ans était pas ya 15 ans
saab a atteint ça fait mal et d'ailleurs
j'ai gagné aussi contre goody femme mais
elle était jeune 12 13 ans aussi ça fait
quand même plaisir à 4
98 ces présentations 1,98
ça date un j'ai perdu normalement
qu'enfin je veux dire c'est pas si
facile quoi j'étais grand maître déjà à
l'époque
bah oui j'étais bon gt26 c'est
impressionnant quand même avec wade fait
j'ai perdu toutes les finales simple nom
du père du tour comme cavalier ça
pourtant je suis je suis assez connu
pour être un bon finalistes ouais tu est
réputé pour être un très bon joueur de
finale ouais mais pourtant j'ai perdu
tour contre cavaliers ok j'ai perdu ce
cavalier trois pions
j'ai perdu bonjour j'ai perdu j'ai
abandonné dans les footballeurs opposé à
l'hyper cognant plus tard pouces couleur
peau et de sébastien petit battu vichy
j'ai battu krainik j'ai battu adams dans
des finales olaya paf où pranger 2 1 en
paca kg et 3 mais je n'en ai du coup si
l'ipad jour h5 pour le menacer
ouais bah oui bon après tout et flûte là
il est pas mal la loi il va bien même si
les vols il défend tu vois là c'est deux
points quand même que maxime y prend il
prend l'ascendant cas même dans les
parties il ya une différence que nos
milieux funes à 100 cette année pour sur
ces speech à ce que les joueurs le
prennent beaucoup plus au sérieux que
les années précédentes vu en par rapport
à l'absence des tournants réel ça m'a
vraiment mais je sature sent vraiment la
différence
bah on l'a vu déjà tissés au fil des
années avec les rapides et les blitz ou
et les buts surtout
et puis tu sens la venue de plus en plus
fort
c'est ça tout le monde s'en foutait
avant nous et tout d'un coup ils ont
tous ils sont tous mes dessus toi parce
qu'il y avait de plus en plus de qualif
en blitz de tourner ensemble et il y
avait des grandes chaînes tour en blitz
et et maintenant on a un peu la même
chose avec internet ouais ça fait la
même mutation est donc forcément ils ont
rien d'autre rien d'autre à faire au
final même les ouvertures sa sert a pu
enfin tu vois c'est on peut plus
travailler comme avant
et puis dernièrement vie à un moment
donné quand tu joue pas depuis un an
deux ans tu vas pas continuer à faire
nous vous tu vas pas à continuer à
chercher nouveautés sur nouveautés en
fait tu peux pas un moment donné bah oui
mais bien sûr et puis c'est pas
exactement je peux pas jouer
actuellement les mêmes choses qui ont
vraiment l'égalisation d'un printemps
quand même pour nous c'est plus tu vois
là c'est faut trouver quand même des
trucs plus intuitif que tu peux pas
sortir 40 coup de théorie à chaque fois
et quelques libéraux qui arrive à le
faire pas mal son 1/4 la wii tout
reprend des 4 la tour est un peu bizarre
mais on n'arrive pas à gagner le pion à
4 justice où j'essaie déjà bien là le
cat
ouais ouais enfin tu vois la grande
diagonale elle est plutôt pour les
blancs comme là je pense qu'il est plus
mieux du tout en fait maxime voire
limite ou un bien précis qui a le jeu de
pions sur cases blanches qui limitent
bien le fouet du coup il va pouvoir
faire un jeu sur quasiment avec les
chevaux ils fouet ouais il va jouer
autour d un écueil dessin quoi ça va pas
être facile
bon après ça va qui a des seins qui va
jouer vous prend qui on prend un essai
s'en est probablement cahier des cats à
ses patrons est même celle ci nq haut
rhin ouais bah oui oui bon ok de la sava
il peut jouer ces six là en fait je
pense ces six dames c'est cette horde et
8 pouces et 8 des cinq trucs comme ça
ouais ok il a besoin dans deux
d'empêcher un cavalier des cinq dont il
s'estime cola c'est pas possible en
parce que parce que calais dès le 2
apres kalyev capter des snacks les cases
c'est si ça peu suivi de dams et 7 comme
tu dis tourbe et des huîtres ou s'est
vite et là avec les blancs en fait il
n'a pas trop quel dessein qui c'est
important qu'il est actuellement pour
jouer pour jouer les case la case noire
auquel assure g4 il veut faire quoi
maxime g4 c'est logique pour les dames
j'ai trois dames proches trois vêtements
ouais ou même simplement cavaliers des 5
enfin il n'y a pas en fait je vois pas
davantage à voir pousser ses pions
sortez vos cinq ans après ça peut
toujours être un pion h3t pas forcément
content avec les blancs rapide sur gk
qui va jouer p5 ses doigts ça doit être
ça son idée il veut
il va exploser un peu cette position
auger prend h3 ok c'est pas mal mais
mais c'est par g proches 302 il veut
faire quoi bon il va faire faux prince 3
en fait il y joue c'est 5 en premier sur
fond proches trois tours gier il a peur
de se prendre un cavalier 5 après
peut-être mais il a pu il va pas tenter
c'est même un truc tactique je vais dire
maintenant si tu prends tout il ya un
quart et prend le cas depuis onze ans a
annoncé y aura six f 16 f 7 7
ouais mais tu pourra prendre h 3 puis
prendre le cas depuis prend b2 pour 19,6
se rhabiller cavaliers pro b cinq
attaques des six donc un peu bizarre ce
b 5 comme poweo et l'ordre à coup si on
lâche 3 peut-être que tu sais tout
simplement tour j'ai un suivi de
carrière
quatre des cinq voire qu'étrangers 6 ça
pouvait être quand même dangereux benjie
cette île est obligé on sent quand même
que depuis ce coup peu 4 la position
allait pas si facile pour les noirs je
suis étonné qu'il ait pas fait tout
reprend tout reprendre peut-être qu'il
n'aimait pas trop prise prise faut aussi
ce tournant décisif ou conséquentes
hockey et on prend c'est pas mal ce faux
proches 3 l'effet tour g1 il va tailler
le roi est très faible alors anwar est
très faible et noir blanc et
inattaquable il a heureusement il a il a
trois minutes maxime parce que ok je
pense pas que ce soit vraiment moins
bien pour les noirs même peut-être pas
du tout mais c'est juste plus dur à
jouer avec trois milieux qui devrait
pouvoir mais sur cavaliers
il va faire tour à chouette je pense
ouais non non c'est juste chiant à jouer
mais ça doit pas être moins bien
investir en russie m états d'âme en rêve
sista tour ans a chuté envoyé ces quatre
mêmes du vrai contre je je pense que la
différence de temps le compense où elle
le fait que la position soit dur à jouer
toral schwyz et pour préparer d'arriver
si ce n'est pas se prendre dans les cinq
échecs
oui c'est que le foutu lui trouve
vraiment pas de case mais fo 17
là c'est pas grave tout rejet trois
dames m6 encore il n'ya pas de cavalier
projet 6 c'est beaucoup de pièces alors
qu'elle prendrait si c'est rien
oui mais du coup quoi sur 2006 six pack
allié proche de 6 du coup c'est pas
grave ça évite peut-être je pense que il
évite les projets 6 il a peut-être peur
d'une bulle d'où le gard mais c'est pas
tout rejet cinq bons coups un très bon
coup menaces cavaliers h5 évite de 9,6
ça a été loupée par maxime c'est
peut-être fallu faire un dame m dames
b2k voyage cinq noms balle assez
compliqué la statue bien compte deux
fois il y aura match ça c'est magnifique
tour h80 f8
merci merci pour ce coup droit fuite pas
compris vrai nom magique attache 5 c'est
vraiment inutile quoi tu te mets dans le
8 mai dans le visent et après c'est
difficile c'est parti très complexe est
normal de faire des erreurs un moment
donné oh oui oh là là j'ai pas dit que
ce n'était pas normal
kevin m'a alors je sais bien etienne
mais c'est pour le pour les spectateurs
non après oui je suis pas que non mais
après maxime et joue tellement bien que
je voyais le doigt je veux jouer
vraiment au top quoi pour les séries
avec des maquillages 14,5
non mais tu vas h 4 h 5 tu as même mais
moi ça me parait tu vois je me dis non
mais ça coûte j'aurais jamais fait ça
paraît trop bizarre en fait quand tu es
en partie il y en a tellement de partout
qu'à un moment donné tu glisses ah ben
là ça va partir tu auras d'autres
preuves de et le pion le pion c'est la
tour g5 qui est il va jouer
jfg caillage 5 ok donc c'est quoi tour à
deux tours est venu mangeront apprend
ces trois âgé qu'elle et h5 presse
prises ces deux tours h1 et d'amener
delattre tmb deuxième décade le mans
gagne mesdames b2 et c un crm imparable
et pertes probablement ce conte
voir je pense il a trouvé un regain c3
c3 ok il n'est pas obligé de joie gfg
calèche 5 mais si elle ne joue pas il
est clairement moins bien que les blancs
[Musique]
donc tête des dames des quatre en
premier ou alliés l'envoi wayne on les
regarde s'il ya pas un truc forcé mais
là il a vu la variante
après il ya peut-être de 5 hectares mais
on va voir du d'amd si tu voyais tout
cas lieu de genre de fou b5 qui va
tomber
ça devrait aller ça donc il a fallu un
bon coup je pense même pas mais ce
combat magnifique termine à dos bon on
sent que le match va pas être il devrait
s'il continue comme ça il va pas être
très serré mais bon heureusement c'est
maxi mais on va prendre plaisir à
commenter ce père que je l'espère par
match derrière j'espère voir maxime en
demi puis on verra match sari compte
magnus si magnus résiste ouais non non
plus là il joue quand même bloqué la
partie elle était hyper intéressante on
regarde pas le résultat voire regarde à
saran joue il rejoue la même bon vous
avez vu toutes façons je crois qu'ils
ont pas le droit d'avoir les aides
pendant les entre les parties
entre-temps pendant les pauses ils ont
un droit d'avoir des aides non je pense
pas mais bon trois sondes a décidé que
c'était pas la peine je crois qu'ici
peut-être une épouse mais entre juste
entre les portes serrées entre les
parties non mais je crois pendant les
pauses ils ont le droit pendant les 3/4
mais quand j'en avais parlé que j'en ai
parlé avec vlad et j'en ai parlé avec
avec maxime du coup avec les deux j'en
ai parlé de la rigolade pour great food
et maximise en fait c'est tellement
épuisant que tu si tu te remets encore
trois quatre minutes des chèques pendant
la pause tu finis juste pas le match en
fait ouais mais des fois tu peux juste
donné un coup soit dur je vais tout
répète pas c'est ça mais il m'a dit en
fait tu vas pas faire d'appel ou quoi le
sais c'est pas possible
si ceux ci mais si hockey si c'est
nécessaire
en fait sur des trucs comme ça non parce
que bon mais voici un coût qui est
vraiment gagnant un coup vraiment
important c'est un truc vraiment
important mais si à apparat par cas
exceptionnel tu d'ailleurs à vue
je vérifiais souvent pendant le tour
d'avant oui oui bien sûr là il ya
beaucoup plus de parties en fins et puis
on n'a pas le droit et puis peut changer
le monde va pas leur entre chaque partie
et comme non plus ils peuvent changer
complètement d'ouverture entre les c5
donc ouais après probablement pas entre
la 5ème et la 3ème les trucs qui
marchent ça peut continuer mais mais
pour le bullet ces deux choses
donc là il n'a pas échangé ce fou de
cases blanches
il n'a pas échangé sous ces deux comme
dans la partie précédente faut faire
attention quand même parce qu'on n'a pas
les bonnes pièces là avec les blancs
ouais il a il n'a pas forcément morila
l'adq à 9,5 s qui calcule d'amd de
dessins qui peut-être c'est ça qui doit
être en train de d'amd de dessins et
puis on prend des sondes voilà donc dam
des deux mais c'est pour ça en fait je
pense qu'ils réfléchissaient sinon dam
des deux c'est vraiment logique quoi
est-ce que prendre en escale et prendra
fils c'est possible mais on n'a pas
assez de pièces ah bah ça va dépendre
découvrir ça va dépendre on sait jamais
pourquoi pas tu vois là peut-être un
petit là on joue clairement sur les
droits quand même je pense qu'il va
jouer h3 déjà pour commencer puis j'ai
quatre peut-être est à la casse quand
même f4 qui pour l'instant non mais h3
par principe j'aime bien c'est déjà ça
peut vous quel tour à derry donne à 2 ok
d'accord faut pro-adn il veut faire des
princes est maintenant je sais pas toi
dépendant des 8
je vais à tour indien il a pris du temps
donc il a dû il a dû se dire sur faut
prendre à deux je vais faire quelque
chose alors est-ce que deux dames
prendre des beats tour prend en tout
reprend 1,7
je sais pas j'aime pas trop en fait
comme ça ta première muse gelle potro
d'ailleurs il le prend le pion gems 300
tours à derna du coup un peu bizarre de
la part d'oddo maxi ça a pas l'air
à moins que ça soit un coût
d'extraterrestres c'est ça tombe là il
va nous sortir après maxime souvent ce
que ce que j'ai remarqué dans ces
sessions de vitesse quand même c'est
qu'il a des baisses de régime
ouais il peut être très très bon et tout
d'un coup et tout d'un coup il a une
grosse baisse de régime et ils jouent
ils jouent beaucoup moins bien ouais bon
en même temps ouais ouais il a besoin
d'être concentré il a besoin d'être
impliqué ok c'est intéressant ce qui
fait parce que tu as la tour qui se
décale quand même alors je sais pas ce
qu'il a pensé jouer cavalier prend 1,6
en jouant tour à des uns ou pas où il
s'est rendu compte après que où il s'est
rendu compte qu'il était déjà vide après
faut prendre je ne sais pas j'ai pas la
clé mais en tout cas c'est intéressant
parce que la dame est très loin tu vois
tout comme des 5
la dame est le fou aussi est très loin
ta tour 3 à la tour qui va qui va se
décaler non ouais c'est peut-être à
seulement un centième paraître écharpe
je te le dis franchement sans frais v3
ni rien ça me paraît très short 1
puisque le flanc à deux ils contrôlent
tout loria bas il a loupé fou prend 1,2
voilà en fait il a dû penser que des
princes 5 c'était vraiment fort sur
l'instant il a click click and choc elle
a quand même eu quatre ou cinq qui fait
que sur cavaliers prend et adam prime
fiscale mme saewyc cavaliers pro 5
probablement une prison débute d'abord
mais le truc c'est que les avec les
blancs tu veux tu as rien voiture est
l'étranger si c'est quand même ouais
mais que les projets s'ils savent j'ai
rempli cette pure et dure un an je
voudrais ce cavalier prend pions prend
1,5
ouais mais même cavalier bouge que j'ai
4 tu vois ne s'est pas encore hyper
percutant oualata menaces ouais ok c'est
pas hyper percutant mais donc c'est pour
ça que j'ai peur qu'ils aient un truc
par exemple la tour prends ton rang tout
8 peut-être je sais pas on va voir ouais
ok ça c'est non mais ça joue encore à
temps c'est pas si facile j'ai pas dis
que ça perdre et j'ai dit que dans
l'absolu ça doit non bien sûr mais après
ça et que si tu gagnes eft a quand même
quatre pions pas scellé après un ouais
mais tu as vu de l'autre côté
s'il est si les pièces elles se
regroupent
le fou est très fort ah oui il fait même
sa tranquille 5 il ya des recettes tu
vois
voilà ça c'était bien joué de sa part et
si chat et h katia moussaoui ahmed hamou
7 c'est horrible ouais si t'as pas de
menace vraiment tranchant tu vois tu te
prends des trucs comme ça un seynois et
tu peux pas faire dame sait si si si je
menace d'armes prohibées 5 pour tard
était un peu et tours 17
ben ouais mais je mens sur d'amsterdam
cette île veut dams et si justement
c'est ça hein
ok ok ça joue un peu ouais c'est ça en
fait c'est un peu ça joue sajou ou sajoo
suis pas ok j'ai dû renoncer tendu la
main
non mais ok ok je peux pas dire ce que
je pense c'est normal et yan paquette
obligé pas non plus 50
t'es pas bien grave suis pas bien et par
contre je pense que son sacrifice il est
enfin fo prend à deux il a il pensait
des prendre 5 et il a fait cas les
proches si ses paroles parce que pas le
choix
et puis aussi ok c'est pas vraiment
clair lors des huit donc tac tac tac s
qui commence reprise est une entrave 5
mai commence par h5 ouais voilà c'est
compliqué là il a redit à shinko way
rally on va garder on va garder les
sinko pour les positions qu'on a gagné
sinon on va se retrouver à court de
coûts paris veut pas prendre ces cinq
pour couvrir cette case là au passage
deux hommes des doutes et d'amd devenant
espion donc tu d'objets 5,6 peut-être
une à nantes parce que je sais pas ah
oui la cave a lieu deux ans menace avec
ans la dame se ranger 5,6 l'adami en d2
il y aura carré lieu de le fou c'est 2
est mal placé un bas depuis je te dis
quoi en début de partie la wii mais ce
qui ne change pas ce fou maxime et dames
prendre b5 et dames 3 4 non mais ça
paraît trop si bah moi je pensais que
d'hommes promet-on justement que tu
mérites ans ok j'ai peur de me faire ma
taille qu'un dam des deux qui avaient
lieu deux dames f4 genre de choses ouais
ouais c'est je pense qu'il veut way ou
là je crois que ça a l'air heureux si ça
perd pas tout de suite car ça fera mal
ce que ça va menacer qui est rangée de
maths battant s qui menacent quelque
chose avec les noirs oui même que les
français 3 donc un relief 4c sur sa
menace match peut pas faire g3 et kg de
maths
ouais je vais devoir jouer ouais tu vas
faire quoi qui a rédigé deux rois f2
d'amd de roger 3 way est sûre d'un
procès dont il veut donne gestion proche
c th 6 ou de 9,5 c'est peut-être des
jeux de rôles donc et le trick de
marloux parme au pied des cavaliers
affichent quatre carrés de 6,1 qui fait
mal problème c'est que la dame des deux
cyprès c'est terriblement ok next
mcdonald's à mach 4 wii noire y en a
trois
il a mal géré son ouverture et l'a pas
sentie
ok on va tenter quoi elle a tenté la
tête de maximus complexe de la montre et
la bête je vais la mettre à côté pour
son art et à retenir est assez complexe
non c'est bon c'est bon t'inquiète mais
attend il est il est encore dedans
ouais je viens de voir ça tu vois je me
base de regarder tout de suite parce que
sur dante vite il veut peut être est ce
qu'il ya un dame g5 contre échec pour
entrer dans la finale elle n'est pas si
simple simple à première vue elle n'est
pas complètement simple parce que le
cheval il est un peu ouais puisque la
majorité
ok il défend bien aller etienne ça
défend pour le moment ouais ouais ouais
côté français au l'horreur je veux voir
la tête de maxime mai mais je crois que
je fais pas il est déconnecté maxime
terribile reconnecter ça va prend la
déconnexion qui a pu faire ça va les
tenir en laisse un nom ça va ça va il
s'est reconnu qu'il était déconnecté de
trois secondes ça va ouais mais ça ils
aiment pas mais non non non ça va
tourner etienne il la tient vous voyez
les barbelés bros comme g5 qui jouent
cette finale ok ok belle eva n'a pas
voulu rentrer dedans de base c'est pas
possible ça ouais mais attends c'est pas
sûr qu'il soit gagnant bref 6
or le roi il est quand même fort il a
pas besoin de vous re f6 tout de suite
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle oui ok ce que
pour le moment il a acheté 10 hockey
affi 6,3 et 6,6 et il est même gagnant
hockey aux effets du temps mais wife 6,6
thugs arrive à gagner
bah oui pourquoi pourquoi il faut à 4
fort ah non
d'accord bon c'est drôle ça ça va ça
solide maxime voilà quoi j'ai juste un
problème qu'elle a gagné 1 point et
l'eau du coup il en a raté une la
première il en a sauvé une la deûle à la
troisième ça équilibre en quelque sorte
ah oui c'était terrible j'ai pas ok je
le vois mais j'ai pas de jeu peut pas
envoyer des petits des petites roses
dont victimes des petites fusées à
s'était pas les fusées lasser les
barbelés ouais vous regardez les fusées
pour pour les victoires
cabal défense allez ça repart qu'est qui
par an ces six y avoir peut-être un coup
de il va essayer de jouer avec cinq noms
comme tout à l'heure bah oui bah il un
peu les styles de position qu'il a mis
en cause by joue pas mal joue pas mal il
est fait un bon début de match sur canal
hier trois jeux concile veut faire au 5d
mk les g4 typique
il ya le vis-à-vis g7 b2 donc il fait
des cinq direct hockey ou la imagine une
petite danon recettes a d'ailleurs tout
de suite aussi s'ils y pensent
il y pense il se tient mais attends
c'est pas hyper dangereux à ce fou dans
le dense vis-à-vis le roi danse
vis-à-vis l'acei les pages hors pages à
tout dépenser tout de suite il envoyait
aussi pour un cavalier gf38 irak comme
un canal étroit que les jeunes ont des
cats
mais bon au cavalier prendre cinq
vainqueurs et les prend oui et puis là
tu te sois tu fais mc2 soit petit rock
même là c'est pas très grave tu vois
dedans des cavaliers f3 et a même fait
preuve 3 il faut prendre les deux tours
b 1 il faut prendre cet appel et bloquer
c'est dommage que c'était pas loin non
ouais mais bon ça va très bien pour les
noirs tu peux par exemple je pense que
tu dis si tu peux prendre avec 3 et
jouer des 5 tu te sort ce pion c'est le
pion un peu commence un peu puis on
arriérés mais ce milliard
en tout cas ça te permet de contrer le
centre quoi ouais ben oui si tu as
beaucoup de cours un tabac presse que
t'as bu cavaliers fds
non il ya peut-être qu'elle des quatre
élèves de cet iron jetons pingret sur
calais prend il peut peut-être joué fou
prend aussi il faut prendre puis on
prend mais il ya 17 ans l'air ok non il
va jouer cavalier prendre cavaliers
prend mai à cannes vsat en l'air tout de
suite tu pense qu'il peut prendre tout
de suite je suis presque n'aurait jamais
mais bon ouais c'est tu prends b79 aux
as 3 ok on va attendre c'est un peu
compliqué comme variante tout ça mais
moi je pense que mon goût et ça c'est
complexe mais ouais c'est probablement
ce qui là parce que carly apprend qu'à
rallier prend on a dit quoi petit rock
peut-être des 5
c'est ça son idée ouais je garde le
cavalier f3 faut prendre et de coude
parce qu'il faut ouais ce qu'il faut à
ces bons qui passe quelque chose pour se
débarrasser de ces options s'il fait pas
quelque chose vite il va être moins bien
comme la partie d'avant la partie
d'avant il avait été moins bien avec les
deux fous enfin la partie d'avant celle
là bas de la dernière où la lune les
noirs bon on va voir ce que fait les
vannes mais en tout cas plutôt bien pour
moi qui fout des cartes ra d'accord il
veut protéger son sont fous quoique le
fou soit protégé dans les égéries 4 mais
ça peut pas être un bon coup faire ça
c'est pas les gars c'est spectaculaire
c'est un coût qui montre que tu as pu
davantage avec les blancs c'est pas mal
quand je joue un coup pareil bafoue sont
rarement bien placé au centre de
l'échiquier en début d'un début et
milieu de partie quoi déjà là il peut
envoyer un sit-in go way quelle est
l'idée c'est 5 fu b de vous jouer quoi
tu penses qu'ils vont trouver pas toi
qui bénin je sais je sais c'est que je
pense qu'il va jouer fou prend le 5 mai
non mais ok mais même qu'elle a lieu
prend c'est presque mieux pour les noirs
déjà ça s'est il faut des quatre c'est
spectaculaire donc sur ces cinq
poubelles d'oeil à carey price 3
puis il faut reprendre oui tiens je
pense je pensais à quelles épreuves de
huy
ah oui à tout yat au hockey non je
pensais à calais point f de wiki à
l'épreuve trois bien sûr vraiment merci
asymco à y prend ici j'ai loupé ça ok
mini site de deir évoqué raid français
cinq noms ah oui pardon non mais qu'est
la dépression mais qu'à rallier prend et
ce qu'il veut ce qu'il veut en fait je
sais pas ce qu'il veut parce que vous
prend on fait juste au pire fou prend
pour bouger des cinq noms ouais voir
tourbe et 8b cinq ici ou d'amos elle
abrite pas moins bien même son cavalier
il est trop loin deux des cinq ans fait
et même s'il va arriver en dessin qui va
arriver trop tard
donc là il va jouer juste pour baie
sainte maxime où des 5 il a joué tout en
2003 les joues pour 10,5
ou peut-être ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre
peut-être qu'il va jouer juste h 5
points juste la position elle est
correcte
moi je partirai pour des cinq par
principe mais oui c'est pas obligé vrai
papa du tout en réalité
moi j'étais plus pour tous ramer 8 à 6
bessin tôt pour dire la vérité là j'aime
pas trop parce qu'après il va se prendre
là cavalier ou quatre qui a laissé 3 ou
calais berck et c3 donc il faut qu'ils
jouent des 5 mai des 5 c'est pas si
c'est pas mal ça peut ouais bah il va
jouer des cinq au bon moment
probablement je sais pas où on va
je sais pas cavalier brd 5.425 ouais
mais c'est que c'est dur on attaqué sur
cases noires parce que l'autre qui l'a
beaucoup de pions joue deux cinq majeurs
la taxe sur le roi elle est difficile à
mener bah il n'a pas joué cinq vraiment
pour attaquer moi c'est juste ça
automatique de bord faut pas faire ça
dans vos parties encore un faut vraiment
voir tous développé pour jouer ça c'est
important l'expansion c'est un but de
plus en plus avec alpha 0 et où vous
savez déjà mais
mais bon les ordis maintenant ils le
prouvent complètement que l'expansion
est hyper importante
voilà c'est juste égal non je préfère a
légèrement les noirs mais objectivement
ça au pied avec les blancs qui pensions
un tutu prend des cinq prend 1,5 million
de joueurs d'apsys ici je vais éviter le
drame cavaliers comptent dame fu chi
qu'il peut parce que là il va avoir du
mal à mobiliser sa majorité maxime
mais sur un coup jusqu'à 9,6 alors faut
aussi c'est peut-être fou et si c'est
pas mal comme ça surtout quand on prend
un tour d un peut-être on peut manger
jouer b5
oui je t'aime des 6 et la mamie dec
monde à me 6 et il va faire mieux le
tranquille peut-être même qui peut jouer
un peu qu'elle veut éviter de jouer dame
fou contre damas cavalier est par contre
tout refus si là ils échangent les dames
il va être clairement mieux pour rouages
et deux magnifiques attaque à faire foi
fils dam des trois alors je pense qu'il
va même je le fous g7 pour éviter les
cathos 5 novembre jour ont réussi ça va
aussi bien sûr là il va échanger les
dames c'est juste mûrois g2 san ku
vraiment vraiment mauvais pour moi
whitehorse et assez bien joué par contre
il veut tourner pour ces deux tribunes
aux jeunes c'était ça son idée en fait
mais la loi il joue en pro d2 mesdames
detroit il veut il veut quoi en fait il
n'a pas d'âme heures je préférais d'amin
je préférais d'âme des uns d'ailleurs
que dame détroit parce que là ah ouais
enfin ok ouais ouais enfin c'est bien la
crise prises ouais ok dam des airs et
tour aller bah oui moi je trouve que
c'est pas très bien joué en fait
qu'est-ce qui peut pousser ces noirs et
sur dame prend prise roi là il peut pas
faire 4 5 maintenant pour essayer de
couper une connexion et ramener le roi
comme ça on s'agrippe plus de connexions
là on est déjà dans les finales je
n'avais pas su vite je veux dire la
place de roy f1 c'est ça qui va attendre
un peu loin la c3 auquel bien jouer
bombay 5 j'imagine
un live et c'est je suis pas sûr que ce
soit les noirs qui pressent un final la
gemme par là ce qu'il a fait j'aimais
bien b5 pour le hula j'aime pas ce qui
l'a fait roi fit recettes
c'est pourquoi ce roi besseling qu'il va
faire il veut peut-être juste filer le
pion et revenir avec la tour mais là il
a fait deux trois coups bizarre parce
que il peut plus du tout mobilisé sa
majorité arabe et 5 3 3 et 7 3 6 3 c3 c3
prendrais tu veux les rois c6 est tourné
en un jour ok ouais c'est un peu étrange
un jeu de la corde mais je voyais pas
d'autre des idées là par contre c'est
bien joué de la part de les vannes oui
même de maxime ya fausse est maintenant
méchant si leroy b 5 3 6 7 6 et akalé
c33 bessette qui est resté chez les 15
ans et 3 il commencera à défendre là-bas
aussi il est pas bien la maxime
pourquoi je 7 kg 5
il ya toujours des risques jamas la tour
d2 bien jouer ouais mais bon tour c'est
vrai bien joué aussi sa double tranchant
demain ça peut ça peut être juste c3 c6
ses gammes probablement mais moi ils
m'inquiètent leur âge tu as dis tout de
suite à quelques toits roi c3 c6 et à
des coûts comme ces quatre c'est hyper
chaud en fait parce que ça peut vite
très très mauvais pour les blancs là
c'est vraiment on est vraiment entre les
deux après 5 le roi il n'est pas déjà ce
qui est spectaculaire pour pour un roi
en plein milieu comme ça donc tu vois on
ne peut pas savoir
en tout cas ça à partir pour race et 6 4
3 6 6 1 6 4
et dommage qu'il n'ait pas joué plus
vite recettes parce qu'il pouvait louper
il pouvait louper le brief en jouant en
prenant plus de temps c'est ça là il a
laissé le temps de voir le
l'autre hic 44 et donc c'est pas mieux
pour les blancs mais poussés 3 je pense
qu'il va revenir en gc haye parents
heures hu a fait sa part en n'importe
quoi là alors là c'est chaud etienne et
à tous peuvent pas la f5
il va monter ça peut ressembler la gamme
il prend sur catia fou prend f4
travailler jeunes ont 4 kg si ça les
bonnes a beaucoup de chance de pas être
complètement perdant encore mais ça
s'est calmé 4 le ccaf fait plaisir en
général dans cette
on en parle depuis tout à l'heure très
important que yahia va tenter la raison
de matha lemon way ben ouais c'est chaud
autour des 6 skieuses synchro faut
prendre jusqu'à ton pranger ci seront
âge c'est ok pour ouais mais il va
tenter de ramener le roi henri vii ça va
être chaud ouais difficile de dire ce
qui va se passer l'un je pense qu'avec
le avec le temps je prends les blancs
tous les jours ici bat à perpète déjà
automatique
maintenant oui voilà il ya pas qu il ait
g6 ou là bas maintenant cicr chaud c'est
terrible a hélas pas f2 parce qu'il y
avait un temps par f2 quand même qu'elle
est c'est dur de savoir si quelqu'un y
gagnons pas la main la cellule ayant le
plus riche et très grande c'est nul
maintenant ça me bouffe mais il n'a pas
il n'a pas très bien joué les gars je
pense qu'il a loupé un gros truc pas
rester hyper tendu il a joué roi g8
ouais ouais c'était ma façon à dire vous
pouvez pas savoir
ok bien jouer cette partie là c'était un
beau finish le sait il se défend les
bonnes puisque peu de temps il est hyper
dangereux il ya des positions qu'on
on perdrait pour mais on aurait perdu la
clé d'un coup là enfin moi surtout la
finale avec les noirs avec les blancs
non mais un moment disons qu'à un moment
il a commencé à se défendre quand ça
tourne mal il a super bien avec le roi
des sept matches avec la deuxième fois
dans ce matin qui se défend bien bien
comme ça ouais toutefois f6 c'est quoi
c'est comment s'appelle cette ouverture
s'appelle berlinoise même cette variante
là ou pas d'ailleurs
ouais
la berlinoise solide mais ça c'est pas
genre hyper égalisant comme position
alors tu sais qui est ce qui a remis à
la mode se tourne entre autres magnus
aux maximes maxi le gagner plein de
partir comme ça c'était c'était le tour
de magnus qu'il avait joué là contre car
yakine oui moi après bah maintenant
c'est hyper lamoise de hockey maintenant
ça vient quand même de bien stabilisé
quoi mais il ya 4 5 ans regagne quatre
ans je dirais il ya quatre ans maxime il
a battu sa révision sauf un ou des très
facilement quelques parties avec se
tourne donc c'était encore considéré
comme comme vraiment facile par contre
là on voit que le cas les g3 est très
mal placé parce qu'il est bloqué à part
bloqué par mme khuong lui serait pas
d'âme bercy c'est ce que c'est loupé bon
c'est très compliqué comme position
parce que les noirs manque de
développement petit peu quand même mais
on tapait un pion mais bon ok g7 qui a
passé trois d'un pro b de 9,3 tape avec
le fouet tu veux c'est ça je sais pas a
priori ça les complique pour du foot tu
vois c'est la foudre à voulpaix faut
prendre quatre comme maxime way le trick
mais il avait vu tempo en les bonnes
puisqu'il a réfléchi quand même assez
longtemps avant de le jouer maxime non
plus la peur du tout temps là je vois sa
tête c'est la teneur très content non
aucun des deux n'avait vu en fait aucun
n'avait vu toi
non non plus pas de jaro ne l'avait pas
vu nous on n'avait pas vu personne
n'avait vu mais géré même les vols jouer
ma vie alors attends on va quand même
expliqué sur fou prend la fuite qui a
fait preuve de l'échec
roy croit fuite ou faut prendre mais
c'est la limite parce qu'il prend
affut'pro tgv temps important donc ça
fonctionne et donc dans la partie après
donc il a pris le pion à des 4 et là ces
avantages noir clair et net il est un
peu dans le dur maxime il est un peu
dans le dur il reste combien de temps de
quarantaine de minutes 30 mai au quai
pour être précis c'est ce que qu'est ce
t'en penses
si je fais tourner une petite position
pour l'italienne qui conseille vas-y
est ce qu'on a le droit est ce que tu
fais que me permets nous permet
d'utiliser la souris je crois je sais
pas en fait je suis parent honnêtement
je suis pas au courant des règles en
dehors d'eux
je suis pas au courant fait non mais
parce que on commente sur trois comme la
wii ok je vais attendre
bref je vais attendre que la position
soit bien un moment bien clair pour
regarder d'autres trucs vite fait vas-y
vas-y vas-y
est ce que tu vois qu'il a un petit peu
dans le dur avec les blancs qu un
est ce que maxime il a la possibilité
sur un match comme ça de switcher vers
des 4 ouais ouais je pense je pense
qu'il va switch ou après il peut
switcher vers berlin
enfin vers la finale de la ravine al rai
d'ailleurs la hilal il a été l'un des il
répétera pas c'est sûr après il peut
revenir s'il ya une petite voici une
petite idée vite fait il peut revenir
sur l'italienne mais pas d'un pas tu
vois pas dans ce contexte la cua sais je
trouve un coup vite fait je vais je leur
envoie une petite photo adoptent quoi
donc
il a fait h cinq mois il a un peu de
contre jeu mais bon le truc c'est qu'on
va pas y eut ce cavalier n'arrive pas à
participer quoi ré pas encore ou encore
mais qui croit ce serait beau brun way
mais après tu vois il peut par exemple
un coup comme dame f4 l'idée voilà
amédée ch si c'est un cheval qui va qui
va voilà ok là il ya des médecis il veut
jouer d'amd 8 défense part d'amd 8 donc
maxime va jouer table des deux mais le
cavalier là ils participent déjà parce
que ils peuvent sacrifier à tout moment
est-ce qu'il veut reprendre et apache 6
c'est complètement voire le top des deux
c'est bien pourquoi la machine le
problème c'est que tu te heurtes adams
et celle d'ahmed quatre jours chez ba ba
miles d'avoir foi il choisit h33 c'est
pas mal aussi
bon le dames c'est cette dame herkat
existe toujours mais quand elle a
davantage si tu vas être obligé de
manger direct ok d'amd 8 alors c'est
maintenant qu'il faut trouver une petite
dame des huit verges et cinq
c'est là il faut trouver une combine est
c'est ça c'est là où il faut être
faut être ma roue tourne
sa rivière tour 5 et aura peut-être il
ya cavaliers g5 malheureusement
cavaliers g5 a l'air fort force d'âme et
cas de prise d'empreintes ou rugby très
complexe n'a pas complexe très très
mauvais à la ses pions âme et est
instable
maintenant ça fait rien nous sommes des
caps et il se recentre alise ok mais
y'aura pts a réagi siaka réussi ce faire
j'avais un peu de chance là il va jouer
hg
quand j'ai tourné un hoquet faudra
gagner encore un match énorme
battu mais un peu les barbelés là non
gravel côté blanche dans un peu des
barbelés
ouais je crois qu'il va falloir que je
crois parce que genre un peu des
barbelés faisant un petit peu cavalier
si c'est peut-être dam des deux voilà le
petit mur de barbelés qui fait du bien
ouais franchement franchement s'esquisse
par rapport au scénario de la partie je
pense était plutôt content d'avoir cette
finale honneur en réalité pas trop le
choix parce qu'il commençait à prendre
des cases noircies les véhicules échange
de gamme ils perdaient toutes les cases
noires pouvait pas se le permettre
ouais je pense je pense ça peut ça peut
faire nues quand même ce histoire ce que
tu vas faire à 5 tu vas quand même
échanges et à la tour qui peut rentrer
colonna la colonne de tulle à contrôler
super bien tons purs h5 il est déjà bien
parti pour s'échanger ça peut partir en
nul ça beaucoup moins mais des choses
des choses de drouot faut pouvoir jouer
f3 à f2 quand même après voilà par
exemple est ce qu'il peut faire et
france 2 c'est important des trois tours
trois cavaliers eux deux tu te diriges
l'américain juge d'abord bien sûr il
joue à trois tours trois cavaliers aux
deux suivent hydro f2 ouais ça va te
faire c'est comme ça
tu vois on commence à souffler un peu
parce que dès que son cheval arrive en
des cuatro
même si ce fait changer il y aurait c6
qui seraient abondés par la toile et
onfray thouraya qu'une couleur nous
verte on échange les tours et la finale
deux fois elle est complètement nul
voilà donc là on commence vraiment la
seule idée pour les noirs malice et de
jouer à 6 maintenant est de jouer pour
ces cinq très vite ou cavaliers au cices
hockey life vous pour ces cinq donc
validé deux toits il empêche à ces cinq
peut-être tout de suite maintenant mais
puis on prend qui les prend cavalière
capra qui doubla toile à jouer au hockey
et là car je joue il y en a un qui joue
pour ses 5 et l'autre contre cesson je
pense y affaire qui a aidé quatre
qu'elle ait des cats oui mais roy death
is why he was the way 1 6 3 la c5
après fo 17 c'est magnifique
parce que là du coup il va peut-être
jouer au foot et 3 bien je me sens pas
que les rachats attend tour ça est
encore ok mais là on sent qu'il ya du
mind en mai dommage qu'il ait joué il a
joué sous 17 et maxime n'en a pas
profité du fou 17 mai ce qui pouvait
vraiment profité je sais pas mais
c'était un tempo trop quoi tu vois dans
la position sans que c'est le thème
potro mais attends c'est red rat mort
encore mais juste c'est quoi le set-up
défensif pour les blancs après ces 5
c'est mon problème
est ce que ces cinq car il sait d'eux tu
résistes un peu ou pas du tout c'est ça
qu'il faut manger pour sûr sur cavaliers
prend peut-être fou ces 2 et la finale
avec la tour 1 et cavaliers b3 où il
fait prise prise prise tu as tout avait
pas le temps d'un tour 1 qui avait libé
trois balles à elle perdrait quand même
avec la tour en huit parce qu'il
échangerait il aurait b quattro a mais
il faut trouver un
cool à maxime vite ce qu'il y ait le bon
coup ouais j'ai quatre serres qui en
avait pas celle ci mais c'est ça qui
reprendre c'est pas grave
faut qu'il ait le temps de jouer quattro
appsync coupe il part il a l'air d'être
en retard quand même et ça va pas du
tout mais si même des quatre matches je
la voyais plutôt défendu comme ça aussi
mais ça va pas du tout non non il faut
prendre ces 5 et est ce qui est
peut-être c5 maintenant prendre des cas
prendre des 4 ou 4 j'aime pas du tout je
pense qu'il ya à six il y avait l'idée
roi prend il voulait jouer c'est dès
qu'elle les prend tour série shake le
ballon oui oui le marlou ah oui trouver
un truc ouais bah oui il s'est présenté
là et sur pions propre en bessin
probablement hop je venais deux fusées
trois bambins
est ce qu'il récupère pas le tueur la
juste vous prend 2,5 faut pas se prendre
ces deux noms au papier froissé 7 ce
serait terré mes cahiers français trop à
kiel et des cinq échecs je pense voilà
oui parce que 822 cas est étroit et
cavaliers cavaliers français à un moment
donné mais alors à temps est-ce que
c'est nul ça bah oui moi je veux tour à
chennai tour à charge avec ma vue à
temps mais il n'y a pas mieux non il est
moins bien mais non ouais allés est-ce
que ça en blitz parce que je prends en
considération qui a plus de temps parce
que ça quand tu as plus de temps est-ce
que c'est pas plus simple de jeu parce
qu'avec tes pièces c'est hyper simple de
bouger là attention de ne pas se prendre
qu'à l'épreuve cinq mois mais c'est tout
reprendre 7 nuls et joue pour gagner
ok mais c'est nul quand même droit prend
mais qu'est ce qui fait trois pas en
food aujourd'hui avec le tempo avec le
temps il veut le faire tomber
c'est ça ouais après prend pas
énormément à risque non mais bon c'est
rigolo parce qu'il pouvait jouer tout
reprend cavalli et à voir
roy oui oui avec mais les deux joues
pour gagner ou quoi c'est ça mais ces
marathons tour c'est tombé six tours 6 3
6 1 olala albarn ou non
c'est quoi cette blague mais je vais pas
pour gagner alors pourquoi il a pris en
bécane je pouvais faire tour là-bas et
prendront b5 et jouer lot il a une
seconde pour peu que grimm pas moi je
sais pas s'il aurait gagné après mais il
pouvait la tente et un bas je sais pas
il gagne à 90% je pense j'ai pas compris
j'ai pas compris parce que j'ai eu
l'impression qu'il a joué pour gagner
pendant longtemps
bah ouais non là c'est gratuit pour tout
reprend bekkat c'est ce qu'il aurait pu
faire le tour prend des noces est
immédiat ou quoi pour faire nul ou même
roy booker prize 53.5 food et 3,05 trois
des quatre ils revenaient vers a1
facilement je suis étonné par qui
ouais ouais la jeune homme est tombé 4 c
les gens disent ils sont amis alors oui
ils sont amis mais non mais bien passé
comme citoyen on joue ensemble notre
match de bullet on est hyper potes c'est
pas comme si non c'est pas comme citoyen
jour son ami je veux dire je n'y a pas
que même nous qui sommes vrai mon pote
si on fait un match comme ça je te flag
faccioli tout de suite mais ils sont
potes non agir quand bien même il le
serait oui d'accord mais c'est pas oui
donc oui oui mais quand bien même il
serait pas tant fait oui ouais ouais non
mais là c'est spectaculaire à la bombe
et 4 c'est choquant c'est un peu comme
quand il a perdu ses deux parties là
quand je suis arrivé terrible tient noté
jouer notre premier 4 ça peut mériter un
ban de dix minutes un moment donné ton
combat car ouais on beckett un petit
times a eu de dix minutes pour réfléchir
à tomber 42.2 tard avec des
interrogations
entre parenthèses death note ah oui
voilà ça peut partir oui c'est notre
point d'exclamation à mon avis même bon
coup j'aime bien le j'aime bien mettre
des douteux en fait c'est quand j'écris
ouais un petit doute vrai tu sais par
une pile bouton j'aime bien les douteux
j'aime bien pas su poser une question
mais en même temps tu ok bon par contre
la laddh à manger 5 et j'ai pas regardé
le début mais ça devait être
spectaculaire c'est un peu spécial pour
la bonne nouvelle c'est que j'annonce
corps quand même etienne il est toujours
un point devant d'accord mais fallait
mettre la tête sous l'eau tout de suite
parce que tour contre cavalli attention
c'est pas si facile on dit c'est nul c
nul tu chauffes à 5
non c'est pas si simple moyen ou grand
maître qui me l'a annulée ya pas
longtemps ils avaient ils avaient 18
secondes sans rajout il a annulé sa
revente ou tempo était impressionnant
quoi ok bien oui d'accord un engagement
je pense elle a gagné en fait mais moi
j'ai vu des gens auxquels mois là on
parle d'un tour cheval papa sur le côté
sur le côté il y en a un qui est
dangereux c'est celui que j'ai perdu
contre calce crise et quand on loge et 8
qui est 8 a fui toi c'est ça à g 8 bits
enfin je sais plus où huit noms quand on
a eu 1 8 août
ouais je supplie bref je regarderai tout
à l'heure mais même le cheval au centre
j'ai vu deux grands matches là perdent
donc sans rajout heures c'était des
bunds bund est sans rajout mai mais là
pourquoi pas l'essayer avec une seconde
ouais non c'est non mais surtout surtout
qu'en plus il se met dans la merde tout
seul avancer le scénario complet qui est
bizarre oui voilà donc en chine pour
cali et puis tout d'un coup une fois que
c'est là que tu pousses tu gagnes pas tu
essayes pas quoi c'est même pas tu
gagnes pas manqué là il a fait un
cavalier beckham qui était très très
bien contré par food et deux ans elle
est très jolie
je pense qu'ils pensent et forcé dame
des doms
food et 3 pour manger le fou mais fou
des deux c'est un très joli mais sur
quel français de retour à c'est un
cavalier bouger une petite découverte
savent avec le vis-à-vis tour c'est un
dogme c'est 7
ça permet à level 2 complet devrait
égaliser voire de prendre l'aventage
peut-être pas mais égaliser oui enfin ne
pas être en souffrance assez claires et
c'est vrai qu'après son x 6 on a une
impression visuelle de deux peut-être
quelque chose mais c'est juste une
position pas clair qui est pas clair
marges et un strict sur le tchat
et oui ils n'échangent pas les fous de
cases noires parce que bizarrement a
l'impression que ce fou j'ai c'est qu'il
est c'est bien pour les blancs
d'échangés mais en fait si vous regardez
mes réparti les parties de sébastien je
pense qu'il en a joué pas mal des partis
comme ça dans les rhodes c'est classique
en fait c'est bien pour les noirs
bizarrement d'échangés se fout de cases
noires dont les dents les commence à
peine à dans les dragons comme ça c'est
pas bien pour les noirs mais c'est pas
grave
d'ailleurs il n'a pas échangé il mais
s'en fout en b 6 alors heureusement le
fond en b 6 on pourra vite l'attaqué
avec un cheval 17 qui va revenir par
exemple poussé six cavaliers au 17 ou
détruits ouais c'est une position
attendue est ce que la dame elle peut se
retrouver à court de cases à un moment
donné l'orage 6g 5g pas et tu pour en
tout cas n'est pas très bien placé ça
c'est clair
il a pas très très envie de jouer un f3
dm f2 qui serait peut-être quand même
nécessaire à cause d'aucune son pion h3
il n'a pas envie de le faire mais ça
aurait de double purpose quoi de
replacer saddam sur le gaz correct et de
bien tenir aux quatre quoi parce que là
souvent il ya des tours français croient
qu'ils peuvent tomber ça je sais que ça
c'est un truc encore aujourd'hui c'est
un truc me prend systématiquement le
sacrifice de qualité j'arrive jamais à
les anticiper c'est une horreur il faut
faire attention
les céciliennes ça marche pas très
souvent mais quand ça marche ça donne
souvent des gros avantages ans je m'en
prends très souvent tu vois c'est
d'ailleurs finalement son tour à ses 1
tu vois c'était vrai c'était plus un
truc pour éviter le sacrifice parce
qu'il voulait bouger ce cavalier
surprotège ces deux concernés mais les
noirs la tendance et 8 bat deux fois
déjà
ouais ouais t'as mal placé le cavalier
on sait pas trop ce qui fait ou est bon
on a quand même un peu dans une position
comme la troisième ou la deuxième c ou
quand il a réussi à échanger ces fous de
cases noires à un moment ça c'est devenu
mieux pour le blanc fera quand les
dessins que c'est bien joué
ouais c'est plutôt bon coup droit huit
le jouet food et 4 racaille des 5
c'était vraiment un fort coup bas maxime
il a dû jouer ou pas mais foutez cas tu
fais quoi
je réfléchis il a dû trouver un truc
parce que c'est trop enfin si tu es
obligé de faire quel point les cinq ça
fait aucun sens donc c'est qu'il a
quelque chose cherche sinon tu aurais
pris en d5 directement tu dois tu te
donnes pas ça en fait lorsqu'il y avait
il y avait eu cet honneur peut-être
attend risque à merde je voulais faire
notre mea ça en l'air je vais regarder
aussi aux cinq qui avait prévu six faux
précise d'autre si ce dessin que même
fouassin tranquillement et c'est
d'ailleurs sur les attaques
il push la dame et d'amd 800 et 801
presse à l'air d'être un bon coup et
d'amd 8 salaire très fort parce qu après
qu où la marque de 5-4 dame prend et a35
encore ouais mais à 3,6 ouais mais alors
est ce que c'est c'est très très très
très très mauvais pour les pour les
noirs sobres
ouais c'est ça que j'allais dire c'est
qu'en fait c'est horrible en carélie f3
il ya les deux tours qui vont être
prises il ya cavaliers g5 qui menacent
maths c'est horrible mais il reste
combien de temps sur ce segment de cinq
minutes il reste 21 une minute il ça
veut dire qu'il va rester deux parties
faut peut-être que j'aille remplacé
maxime mais attends c'est pas fait
encore à partir gardam ses sept îles a
taxé de il attaque à cinq
ouais mais tu vois dames 18 ça avait un
peu cette tête en mieux ré voilà mettons
prend des cats étaient peut-être une
fois de côté les bonnes ici ouais mais
là c'est dangereux
puis en moins d aux attaques après 2
minutes 20 contre 20 ce que j'allais
dire il faut aussi prendre en compte les
vraies images de ces pressions maximus
c4 est un jouet encore il laisse
beaucoup d'options à son adversaire et
hélas il peut déjà récup un je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas le résultat c'est
clairement en gagnant pour le blanc mais
nos résultats nous apportiez pas si
clairement c'est quoi qui la dame f4 pas
de bol mais mesdames f4 dams est à tu
peux prendre de la tour j'allais dire
sur apprendre de la dame et on prend 1,4
ça va la finale tu peut la tenir
allez un petit 2 sing ok tu parles
il va nous sortir un petit dessine
cotecna remy je pense qu'il a tiré
depuis un an ces quatre pour éviter
qu'elle et ses 4 c'est ça et bien en
cours cinq ans le site co
mais la fille cynthia dissidia c'est dur
ce cas cavaliers 3 kg 4 là qui arrive
oui bah non c'est reste je sais je sais
je sais tiennent mais je suis en fait à
chaque fois que je vois un plan ouais
mais bon faut pas aux petits il donne
ici
ok j'aime bien d'amr ça fout la merde et
il va faire un petit tour à tour poète
points ouais ouais c'était sûr puis on
se voyait d'ânesse 2.3 maths ou c'est
marlou ça s'est très mal ou b sync ou
non pour tous dessinent comme et b6
causé bien jouer non je sais pas il à
eelv a trouvé un truc là maxime je pense
est ce qu'il a un truc
j'espère à bessines coup c'est très très
très mal ou si ça marche très très fort
mais si plus effarant
c'est l'enfer bingo c'est l'enfer un
petit faux 8 à tours 4
les 5 touring non mais bathing qu a bien
vu avec si peu de temps mais après ça se
voit quand même ça se trouve
même sans avoir tout calculer quoi ouais
mais oui oui non bien sûr mais il faut
le sang froid mais c'est ce que je te
disais il a été il a été très fort les
vols déjà dans son match précédent et
m'a impressionné dans ces moments un peu
clutch tu vois
qu'est-ce qui fait la police et devait
s'agir ici bas il s'est dit je m'appelle
levon je me lef quoi il s'est dit levon
nous à la santé de baky quoi ah mais moi
j'en peux plus de ces règles ça me
savard fois chaque fois c'est quoi
l'idée on fait ce que s'il passait par
pendant cinq minutes
je comprends paraît mais après l'autre
et c'est plutôt pas mal pour maxime pas
ce que ça peu le vrai je pense qu'il va
juste aux toilettes un pour dire vrai ok
mais alors non mais je t'attends 20
minutes mais gère en vrai je pencherais
je le vois pas faire autre chose que ça
parce que je veux dire par là n'aurait
pas choqué des variantes est ok mais
pourquoi il perd pas de temps quand tu
va aux toilettes
ah ça je ne sais pas d'ailleurs comme si
une partie toujours aux toilettes ou
alors c'est vrai je joue comme ça on est
on est on est tout à fait d'accord et
tienne c'est une question que je me pose
à chaque fois mais s'ajuste pas de sens
parce que le stade à la cloque s'arrête
au moins enfin ça dépend si c'est dans
les règles ou pas en fait après si c'est
dans les vagues il fait ce qu'il me le
font tous je m'aligne que ça doit être
dans les règles
c'est terrible après on est d'accord que
pour quoi tu joues
pourquoi tu te lèves
ul le monde vers la santé d'art organes
ça me fait tellement rire à chaque fois
ce truc
non mais c'est suffit déjà évidemment
mais je sais ça fait marrer terrible
mewes les sols avaient enfin il va
carrément donner à bouffer à son charme
enfin le jour il s'est levé en plein
match il allait voir le chat il a pris
avec lui fasse des terribles bénéfique
c'est un beau chat maximum maxime qui
envoie douce et quattro c'est mauvais
signe entreprises
bon bah oui pourquoi pour que votre ba
ça veut dire qui s'est un peu fait
choper dans l'ouverture ils n'avaient
pas prévu
du coup ils tentent des petits trucs
jusqu'à ce qu'ils trouvent le ski va
embêter les bonnes quoi qu un match qui
va être très tendu etienne 1 jusqu'au
bout amont habile à trois partout après
une heure
1h20 de jeu ça sent le match qui va qui
va qui va se devait pas mais ça c'est
pas mal je pense qu'il peut entente et
une comme ça et maxime ça ça peut être
finale perd deux fois les saints passe à
la note près je sais pas ce qu'elle
donne sur l'ouverture parce que je
connais pas les ouvertures de maxime
dans une rame mais ça a l'air sympa mais
en tout cas pour cette partie senior
thaddée beaucaire faith qui par titre en
le chat abba mérité je les ai cherchés
qu'un tour g1 ici ça peut être
intéressant
moi j'aime bien jouer ici à 4 voire
principe sur ses seins qu'on joue à 5
est sûre à 5 on affaiblit un peu d'elle
il faut le jouer là-bas quatre parcours
à ça à 4,5
ça permet d'affaiblir le pion b6 tu sais
ça paraît quand tu te rends c'est 5 m il
a joué à cinq bras le pion v6 en ligne
c'est ça ou quand toi tu joues c5 ça
peut affaiblir à 5 en général c'est
plutôt une bonne chose pour les blancs
quoi
après oui il faut g5 mefou g5 pourquoi
fawcett il fait quoi du fait nul et a dû
sous 3 ok une réussite pour les blancs
donné d'avoir provoqué f6 tu as
peut-être un pion réussissez un jour à
jouer je suis pas sûr du tout je sais
pas j'aime pas du tout ce qu'il a fait
un bond à quoique bon teint soit il est
pas moins réelle n'est pas moins bien
mais ici roi f7 après qu'elle ait b18
quoi qui peut faire non il peut paraître
le fou en b c'est parce qu'il risquerait
de le perdre il peut pas le mettre en
bessin annonce à comprendre en fait ce
qu'il veut faire
si on répète il veut quoi il veut pas
encore mais c'est vrai qu'il y ait ce
qui en fait je vais avoir du ce et sinko
quand même c'est arrivé 5ème place non
je veux dire avec les blancs nike a
échoué et c'est pour ça qu'il a fait ça
avec des coups c'est pour ça qu'ils
jouent à 4 pour éviter tout laissé cinq
devoirs bref cette est-ce que même fou
prend 17 ou reprend 17 c5
ça ne pouvait pas être jouable je suis
pas sûr après faut regarder mais là un
autre côté on introduira 4 à 5 pour
faire ça ça aurait été plutôt avantageux
pour les blancs non dans tous les cas
même époque
oui les bas après je pense que les noirs
jouait pas à cinq mois il le joue
maintenant
là il va jouer à 5 clairement à temps
c'est pas dangereux si avec les ventes
us est à 5 tu ne gagnes pas la colonne
si tu le fais par contre si tu fais à 5
toi même c'est encore plus dangereux
parce que ton pioncer 7 bouge plus et
dès que les blancs jouent ainsi cassé
sinko c'est fini tout bon mais là c'est
plutôt mieux pour les blancs au final
assez désolante je pense que là c'est
gros avantage parce que ok si tu laisses
le fond ans et 6 à 1,5 c'est intéressant
à double tranchant mais
c'est intéressant et les way détour d un
c'est bien joué
ok super mais ça donne quand même
beaucoup kastler chaumont bakir oui oui
non mais c'est intéressant si tu veux
dans le fond parce que tu es moins bien
et e5 ça peut changer les choses est en
fait tourner un c'est très fort parce
que tout surtout huit îles féroé enfants
ouais d'accord ils se cachent droit il a
fait passer la tour donc il a trouvé
tout de suite voilà c'est la tour d r je
pense que là je pense que ce sera
finalement la petite pause l'impression
qu'elle a vraiment servi à maxima bah
oui mais je pensais pas le contraire
mais je veux dire angers dans règle
générale ces noms avec le général on est
on est d'accord mais là il mange un peu
de cas qui je crois peut-être un petit
un petit kaki pam qui part battant ate
envoie un nom ça doit pas être un cas
humains non non non c'est pas un cas qui
tombe c'est en kaki tom cary ajouté ans
parle je vais faire un petit chalet
fraîche ici pour le voir en live
allez là ça se passe bien pour pour
notre maximus g5
oui tu vois il peut pas se permettre de
jouer à 5 avec les noirs mois ont par
contre c'est d'avancer pour maxime de
jouer à 5 lui-même quand même non
qu'est-ce qui joue bien quand même à ce
niveau là etienne joueurs ça joue pas
mal c'est dans web
il n'y a pas un fou prend 17 comprend
hausse annoncée à tours 8
attends attends attends vous prendre
sept ans prendrait cette c5
tu sais ce qu'il y avait il y avait
peut-être se sent tout de suite
ah oui c'est simple tout de suite
comprend je prends ton prendre en compte
et 6,5 et peut-être fou au 7 mai je suis
pas sûr ok ça a joué ça et ça oui
peut-être quelque chose à mais peut-être
quelque chose mais bon à 5 c'est
tellement facile à jouer que 37 way
maintenant il veut l'idée de ces cinq
qui on prend plus on prend fou prend en
france et 7 qui va toujours rodez où le
problème assez que c'est hyper dur à
jouer pour les noirs avec une minute 20
c pouf
après méfions nous parce que les vannes
il en a défendu des complique t
compliqué ouais d'ailleurs rouages et
cissé met en joue et marine en train de
partir de l'autre côté même s'il est
hyper faible sur cases blanches
lecavalier quelque part a failli une
focale mais c'est une double focale j'ai
envie de te dire non ok on a un problème
avec ce fou c'est un esclave du nouveau
nom on peut pas échanger se fout de
cases noires qu'elle rit ça il va
falloir trouver il va falloir trouver un
break bons fous b2 par principe à les
fulbé 2 par principe
est ce que il va pas jouer à il a fait
h3 d'abord est-ce qu'il va pas jouer h5
et h7 tour cette vente nous je sais ce
qu'il est vraiment encore enfin mieux
oui mais est-ce qu'il est mieux au point
de presser encore assez bien joué ça il
a provoqué cinq pour jouer tour g1 et
pour mettre la pression de ce côté là
oui mais c'est quoi son idée là où fait
il faut quand même qu'ils trouvent une
idée un à mon avis va y avoir un truc à
partir à base de h4 ccim corruption
prend je sais pas à mon avis va essayer
de faire péter tous les trucs sur 15
noir à un moment donné dévier le fouet
tout faire péter
ouais il faudrait un petit il fait faire
un petit fou bedo de marleau il faudrait
une petite tour aussi je pense que ça va
ça va toucher un moment fou reçu à temps
et si jamais un arrêt pourra si j'aime
beaucoup etienne tu te mets en face de
beaucoup de choses mais dans un trafic
assez récent regarde tour des alentours
des 1 c'est pas mal il revient ici
white plains huawei s'est ouvert le
procès si c'est ça qui va me prendre des
cats échec
oui l'apparence je vais créer votre
vis-à-vis mais roy f1 l'invite à mais il
va se prendre quatre à eux quatre ces
cinq c5 quand même nom de trois ça
devient à la wii c'est dangereux la
façade de la la on sait pas là ce qui se
passe près les vannes qui contre qui va
chercher skg quartier a passé 5 puis on
prend fou à 3 avait acquis des surplus
en france vous prendrez ici si on prend
des
ce temps prendre cette voie là de façon
faut faire quelque chose
ouvrir tout ça tu te ranger 4 ou quoi tu
peux te retrouver à
dans le grand danger quoi puis on prend
puis on prend qui comprend cavaliers
prend cavaliers h depuis on prend des
quatre c'est quasi matin d'ailleurs même
c5 puis on prend en fou à trois
peut-être g4 puis on prend ces 5 g h et
du coup il fait tour à huit tours à huit
voilà donc bon on sait à quoi s'en tenir
dans le noir est très jours les 2 1 la
lie à vue quatre à temps je prends une
fois et je fais tout ré au quai de deux
échecs à merde mais je suis pas si sûr
ce que ton cavaliers 1 4 il sera sous
pression quand même le catch est
peut-être c5
heureusement crise prises france et 4
way bien galicienne mais on récupère
quatre salles et auquel j'ai katla cedro
facile c'est pas mieux pour les blancs
mais debout s'est donc séparé pour
l'inra non plus hein non non c'est pas
voilà je veux dire après eux quatre ça
pouvait être dangereux mais ces cinq
c'était un bon coup allez moi je te dis
que maxime il va la tenter quand même ça
peut où elle est bonne aussi ça peut
être chaud des deux côtés en réalité
ouais bah les deux vont jouer pour
gagner
elle est devant vous les gars là soit
1,8 y est bien placé quand même en
quelque sorte le fou de cases blanches
et très fort puisque les noirs ne l'ont
pas ok ça va ça va faire drôle
ouf on n'est pas si mal avec une drôle
un monde où les mairies guekam du genre
et ce but il en reste une d'accord vous
avez arrêté à la police avait arrêté le
chrono il en restera c'est plutôt la
réalité
égalité ouais vas faire quoi fouetter y
aller est-ce qu'on préparait pas maxime
en une seconde la kevin en envoyant des
barbelés par l'elysée non non non ça je
vais envoyer des roses
je vous voyais des roses non mais si tu
as le début de la ronde 3 ont fait la
victoire de maxime en direct le début de
la ronde trois sets sur l'italienne tu
vas tu veux la revoir
ouais je veux bien juste une seconde on
voit des petites roses la rente 3 il ya
30 ans qu'est ce qui s'est passé là bas
je suis passé très chaud mais pour moi
c'était fini déjà beau ça va l'annoncer
à jouer à fond et tu me dis on part on
pas moi je suis allé chercher fait la
prépa mais ça va il répète
ok la rosace vous n'est dangereux là à
tan tan tan tan tan tour 1 à 5
ouais qu'elle était peu ouais faut six
pièces ouais 5
ouais d'un v8 oui car il y à farnham à
7,3 oui 3 3 qui prend 3 à 4 d'accord ça
c'est ce qu'il a joué de nouveau par
rapport à la première des 4 way carayos
est ok trois sets 3-6 pousse à aller
ok merci c'est bon c'est fou c'est
dingue tu avais pas aimé je bosse je
vais mettre vite fait un achat ils ont
joué ça pendant
pendant bas c'était des policiers
bah rien de bizarre avec ce qu'elle
céderait les bonnes aime bien il a joué
d'ailleurs contre dépôt il n'ya pas
longtemps aussi mais je comprends jamais
rien à ce truc à elle c'est en fait je
crois qu'il commence chez plus beaucoup
il commençait par kheireddine f3 est
bonne mais du coup ce ouais il a l'air
pas mal la maxime alors encore c'est
encore il n'a encore les deux fous
il va encore falloir et cette fois il va
falloir qu'ils évitent les changes des
fougasses douarin clairement meilleure
qualité c'est s'est quand même fait pour
ça sur quels lieux saints que je pense
qu'il peut prendre quand même rare 7-6
7-6 et la f6 qui peut vous paraître pas
dans l'habituel comme coup mais c'est
vraiment un coup très facile j'allais
dire attends il a une idée concrète
peut-être oui d'accord mais si c'est
juste un peu mieux pour le noir c'est
bizarre ce tu le fais un livre puis on
prendra me prend effet au f5 pas je sais
que tu as vu un mais ouais mais à tempo
là ça me paraît après c'est une formule
1 il attaque et valeo 2 par exemple
tient lieu 2 puis on prend pions prend
d'amd 5 des quatre ouais ok ça a l'air
d'aller pour les moulins qui est assez
simple ok mais c'est sa gries t3 à leur
tour quand même ouais c 3 les sapins
dame cécilia des cinq sur dabo cissokho
b sont ce ces choses là et c'est cette
dame c'est 6 c'est chaud on est parti un
peu leur enjoint ses jouets on peut vite
la part de maxime
je crois qu'il va vraiment lui mettre la
pression sur la pendule quoi qu'il en
soit quoi moi il a l'air assez
tranquille sur le sur la vidéo mais pour
moi c'est très bizarre de pages web
6 e tron qui le mot après je pense très
clairement qu'ils visent
il vise à mettre la pression et
peut-être qui se dit que cette pression
là puisse à elle paiera en plus tard
dans le match
ouais bah c'est 5
le dessin que c'est la variante qui ont
regardé ce qu'en attendant si televen
aronian tu as quand même un max de
pression pendant des heures mais qu'on
connaît pas il avait supporté la
pression et même jusqu'à gagner le
bullet quoi au final on dans la salle r
pas mal quand même ce qui est ce qui
nous fait maxime va faire quoi la c4
fourbe et 7 peut-être que les f4 et
dames eu quatre sur des 9,3 il peut même
jouer c4c quattrocchi par mois mais pas
encore quattro s'est pas encore assez
quattro passe très bien on a gagné c'est
la tienne en d'hectares cette pratique a
peut-être trompé ok en tout cas il a
clairement aucun problème at il géré ces
mêmes allées von den de prendre assez
tôt que tout autant là je te ferai c4
malheur tempo ouais mais après ces
patients parce que peut-être dû prisé à
cuatro entre comme ça il n'y a pas un g6
mco pour faire un fou détresse au gc que
ça se regarde après je fais pas sûr que
ça passe attends je vais pas faire j
sans les coûts directs
j mais ça peut déclencher cheval méprisé
call you do peut-être wef ou des trois
essais 4 mai puis installe à doha après
qu'ubs a d'ailleurs là tu vois il pose
parce qu'il a aussi un coût simple comme
ça prend des quatre qui existait à voilà
oui c'est ça a l'air assez propre aussi
est-ce que tu laisses le chevalet
oui mais l'offre des cinq prises pour ft
vite elle a fait beaucoup mieux un
talent est pas ta structure pas le pion
qui est qui endigue mieux c'est pas sûr
en fait parce que t'es trop f2 et roanne
où il est au tempo près bah je suis ok
lens parce que moi je suis ici j'ai de
la règle et un pour le moment il peut
pas y aller en trois sets qu il la tient
c'est bien joli joue bien les vannetais
[Musique]
ok complexe mais nous sept tours à dos
mais donc est hélas tf6 que tout le
reste du monde après celle là t'en fous
en dessin qu'il est quand même beau mais
là il faut faire attention à calais
détroit donc un petit fou fou à 8 là une
petite baie 3 b3 ok c'est bien maxime il
a peut-être sur pied des premières
fouilles 4 oui d'accord il menacé de
mettre un petit fou ans et d'os l'acquis
qui serait pas mal donc 3,3 bien joué
mais là il reste isatis un iphone 6 1
faut améliorer cette position du roi
lâché max
il décide donc j'espère plutôt j'aimais
bien m6 mais roy g7 ok bon il faut
améliorer opposition du roi qui reste
une 10 dans la cadence incertain la
partie finie dans dans mon plus d'une
minute dix ce sera la dernière et je
pense que ça va être le cas je vois pas
à quel moment cette partie du repas meka
et détroit il menaçait de québec 4 c'est
qu'il est plus mieux je pense max en
réalité il est moins bien ça fait trois
fois dans le déséquilibre fou contre
cavaliers qui là on a l'impression qu'il
est mieux de base et il se fait
graduellement retourner non ouais ouais
je sais pas où c'est mon impression
nantes a raison ça fait deux trois
parties où ils allaient noir vous saviez
au début et après ça devient chaud oui
j'ai 100 kg 5 quand même enfin enfin
coûts au maximum
maxime est ce qu après vous revient
c'est vite dit je ne vois pas la loire
notamment budget 5
tout d'un coup ce faire face quoique
kébé 4 mais bon j'ai 5 c'est bien là
dedans tu avoir peut-être créer du
contre jeu aussi attaqué de l'autre côté
et attention même si on perd mais trois
là on envoie les
les torres sur b non non non non ça va
ça passe donc qui avaient quatre fois
mix est superbe mais bon ça va les
chercher un tour à tour à tour là-bas
tout dans le coup c'est déjà mieux pour
le noir et créer un accident ouais mais
même si si c'est un même f6 way puisque
près cerise et travaillerez tour ici à
ça tu peux en effet tour un tu vois ça
joue un week-end est sûre ils menacent
tourgis auxerrois f2 il ya quatre tours
j'ai deux chiens
oui oui y'a pas tomber lutte terroir à
f2 tout rejet de roanne va encore nous
reprend tout reprend des quatre voies et
bonté mieux avec les blancs non mais
c'est mieux pas du tout surtout rejette
sur wave 2 tours j'ai deux roues avant
tout reprendre de roy prend 2,2 ghz
méditer sur le coup j'ai h dans l'autre
choc
bien vu bien vu mon bac es mais tu as
ton retour à un temps bien ça fait très
très mal
mais d'ailleurs j'ai pas compris son
dernier coup parce que même tour b 8 ça
doit être ok il y avait des saints qui
met ça paraît pas d'engin sa part est
vraiment fort là ouais non mais tour ces
trois tours tomber 3 c'est tellement
risqué
il se fait prendre par derrière c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure quand tu
réussis à contourner ça peut être une
partie importante à pascal et à la pause
avec + 1 après avoir gagné cette partie
ça peut je regarde la partie en fait
c'est oui d'accord à 4 ans fait
l'italienne je les jouais il ya un an et
demi c'est pour ça que alors attends
c'est pas fait encore un tour des 3
éléphants
tondez trop a bien joué s'est pas fait
mon etienne est tombé vu que c'est pas
malin de la force cavaliers ses
cavaliers à 6 à cassis et malin russie
il va retoucher ses 5 et gagne un tempo
sur la tour la tension autour ailleurs
at on envie de jouer 2 bah oui la
magnifique
ces petits coups de tour intervient il
est déconnecté des conserveurs ça je
vois les caméras c'est sa connexion
internet
il bouge plus sur la caméra il est à
celle à koné pourrait pas fait tomber
deux barres parce que il s'est fait
l'écho en fête
parce qu'il est des coûts n'empêche j'ai
h c'est pas mal aussi la whey non ça va
ça va non même pas encore mort et il est
connecté
pas encore mais là ça pour une fois ça
n'est pas de chasse comme non mais je
rigole fait il ya souvent des problèmes
sa chaise comme autant là c'était pas de
chasse calme
c'est très chaud les vents ne pousse pas
le pion pour pas se prendre h2 et sous
bois mais il va pas la gagner du coup à
cause de ça ouais mais après l'avant
corps humain pourquoi il a joué de tempo
après la déconnexion en fait sèchement
va à parce que quand tu es dedans ça
c'est terrible
oui oui je sais ça m'arrive parfois mais
c'est quand même dommage de repousser
six de fou g2a les balles et il peut
encore la prendre il va peut-être la
pousser un petit peu quand même
je ne bougeais deuil doit calculer les
foucades d'abord salon bio pressé ivey
tour f7 bazille vas-y arrive set levels
of fife sinko cavalli assure dès
maintenant pour pessac b quattro
peut-être et tours 5
ok ok on laisse le cheval ans et 7 qui
est pas très bien placé la tâche
hhh 5 h 4 parce que maximilien cavaillé
chaque nom louper peut-être un mois j'ai
cinq là
sous jacques interrogé cinq ans ouais
du coup ils menacent ou grossiste et son
pion à 4 est mal placé bas et là
oublient le foot pro sys tème y faire
grand choix là aussi pour l'atout
premier single 4,54 magnifique et ça va
mater importante importante la décret
les hyper importante
la déco pouvait faire très très mal
ouais moi il part à la pause avec avec
un petit plus à qui est méritée 1 je
dirais quand même sur l'ensemble du
match à etienne ouais je pense qu'ils
pouvaient déjà refermé le match avec
rejoint cette finale deux tours là où je
pense qu'il a un peu de chocs en fait
ouais mais bon on finit sur une bonne
note et puis le plus ça va aller vite je
pense que on voit qu'il a tout le temps
une minute deux minutes d'avancé après
après comme comme dans son match contre
n'est pas au moins les vannes il meurt
il impressionne
je sais que j'aurais pensé tu vois mais
là je suis pas étonné dans le deuxième
match tu veux mais je trouve qu'il est
le sait qu'ils jouent mieux en défense
qu'on est en fait ça sert pas parce
qu'il a vraiment des trop mauvaise
position et tu vois là quand c'est pas
clair il a essayé de pousser un peu au
lieu de fermer la position et puis c'est
pris tour à tour g1 ouais tu mets là
dessus grant hill cité qui doit jouer
quand il sait qu'il doit jouer porte
sommeil joue bien mais par contre quand
ça joue les trois résultat auquel jouent
très bien c'est pas le problème mais
comprend aimé mes joues il joue moins
bien tu me laisses moi un petit peu de
petites minutes etienne je reviens je te
laisse meublaient une petite cheveux
bleus revient dans une minute trente a
garé sa main du coup bah je pense qu'il
ya un mur assez facile qui se profile
voilà je lance le mur
tout seul c'est toujours compliqué c'est
pas une fusée c'est pas la fusée qui qui
se profile
il peut y avoir des roses voilà le pls
le ps se présente des acheteurs le bas
qui s est très facile moi je les
trouvais je les trouvais un peu facile
mais mais certainement pas la fusée la
fusée c'est si maxime la passe ça peut
les roses tout bas qui est ce pas qui
est ce maxime qui doit bien rigoler
ainsi passe bon du coup du coup et je
pense que vu comme ça s'est passé en 5 +
il peut prendre un gros avantage sur le
prochain segment d'accord m à chaque
fois une minute une minute trente
d'avancé dans mes débuts et là en 3 3
une des vannes va devoir jouer beaucoup
beaucoup plus vite
200 g de 100 grammes c'est pour ces pour
kevin qui est partie ravitailler
femmes
et après il ya juste une partie où je
dirai au maximum il était un petit peu
en dessous il s'est vite repris
je crois que c'était bien elle hier il a
fait une vingtaine de parties donc c'est
là il est pas mal il ya vraiment pas mal
ce petit tour à tour g1 là il nous a
tous un peu pris par surprise
c'est quoi toutes ces nouvelles emotes
allégé toujours pas vu maxime au cas où
s'y passe on peut on peut lui faire à
il passera pas pas sûr il est devant on
va lui faire un petit mur de fusées et
comme ça je vais lui envoyer bac s
allait trouver un mur peut-être des
fusées débat qui s ii emote deux mots tu
vois la magnifique magnifique femme
voilà comme ça si son ordi et bloqués
aux portes chaise comme il aura au moins
ça il croit que c'est une prépa qui
arrivent et non c'est la prépa
psychologique aux les petits hôtels
magnifiquement maxime les petits ol est
ce que est ce qu'il ya un modérateur
pour faire un petit sondage sur le
résultat du prochain du prochain segment
ludwig ont fait un petit petit résultat
on propose quoi mais 4,4 tête + 3 et
plus +1 ou défaite en 3 + 1
on peut je pense qu'on peut toucher un
score de dictateur
j'avais besoin d'une pause je t'ai
laissé seuls two way moi j'ai fait des
petits murs j'ai fait faire des petits
murs j'étais pas très bien non mais les
murs ça s'est toujours bien quoi on va
envoyer un petit sondage j'ai envoyé une
petite photo à maxime attentes et bien
quoi mais moi je mets plus trois pour
max au prochain au moins on en parle
plus ça va on est content quand même de
ce premier segment etienne ouais bah
parce qu'il est bien revenu en fait un
petit coup de moins bien mais en fait
même les une ou deux pauses il a une ou
deux parties qui devait perdre
il les a tenus heureusement et c'est
cool ouais c'est cool c'est cool c'est
cool c'est cool c'est cool lancer à mon
avis on avis ça va ça va bien ça va bien
continuer là on a lu on est bien au fait
tu avais un petit un petit problème avec
micha qui mangeait tous tes meubles
quand maintenant
ouais non non non non jugé commencé de
la rive à 14h15 tu vois 14h15 oui
d'accord
donc j'ai pas fait de pause depuis 14h15
tu vois j'avais besoin de du petit break
tu vois là fait du bien celui-là je te
je te cache pas que quand les vannes a
fait la pause je me suis dit est-ce que
je pars en pause au pas ou tu as aussi
ce matin j'ai peut-être je vais
peut-être faire comme les bonnes non
mais après si tu veux faire une petite
pause pendant une partie c'est quand on
en est là c'est une courbe non non ça va
pas je suis bien ouais non mais bien sûr
non mais si tu veux faire une pause fait
là plutôt que je suis bien et maintenant
je suis bien je suis bien je suis
tranquille 1 on a presque un score de
dictateur moi y'a quand même 14 qui
qui peuvent se faire ban à égalité c'est
tampon égalité espérait c'est vraiment
espérer un match voilà espérer mais bon
après on 0 ça va être terrible
jeudi l'énorme favori maximum 0,2 en mai
un plus ha ouais il est favori mais
comme les vannes a battu n'est pas
vraiment un plus un là en plus il en a
fait un petit peu hier maxime gâché
quelques liens et les enfants mais il
m'a dit il m'a dit c'est pas la même
chose qu'avant ça veut rien dire oui
c'est vrai mais là bon vu comme il a
joué le 5 1 je pense qu'en dans le
troisième truc ça va être
je pense aussi mais après je me méfie
toujours maximy peu moite voilà c'est
vrai qu'il suffit d'une erreur a misé
clic une déco c'est ça ah ouais là on
est on est sous le coup d'une déco quand
même aussi
non mais on est sous le coup d'un maxime
aussi tu as des petites baisses de
régime tu vois ouais ouais mais tu as
commencé à 14h20 jetez loupé quoi 14h
c'est un fait grave et quinze ouais mais
après j'avais live avec domingo machin
genre ok et après tu as trégueux le
tournoi dekra quito après haletant à des
capitaux ah ouais t'es tu échoues quoi
céder grosse journée
cc 1 kévin ouais ouais mais c'était
sympa le peut-il avec domingo ouais puis
du concert on refaire live mercredi
prochain à turin est chaud et du coup tu
lui envoyait sur quatre des cinq bars
non pas du tout j'ai envoyé la vidéo
mais ouais je vais envoyer sur la vidéo
m et pèse je n'ai pas j'ai pas coach
dessus encore après t'as vu 4 5 et 4
cavaliers sait si c'est pas mal aussi
oui alors le point ç'aurait pu faire
punto d'ailleurs il ya un sefyu très en
forme qui n'a pas manqué de mentionner
d'un match 4 ouais ça aurait pu faire le
plein temps
ouais donc on va vous mais par contre
après qu'ils aient laissé six cavaliers
f3 s'est un petit peu
non mais là le truc tu vois c'est comme
je vois qu'ils ont peu de temps ou quoi
le cadre des 5 pour leur niveau c'est
vraiment bien quant à peu à temps pour
travailler c'est enfin en fait là je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi dans
le sens e45 est favori dit pareil pour
les gens qui veulent vraiment faire du
travail art d'échec au long terme c'est
bien mais pour les gens qui ont deux
trois heures par semaine maximum
une semaine dans le mois a loué oui mais
bien sûr non mais les deux parce que
après j'ai pas vu j'ai pas encore vu ta
vidéo
meiway ceux qui après peut-être au
niveau un petit peu au dessus à 4,5
c'est pas mal aussi
moi j'ai dit que ça ça tenait jusqu'à
1400 1500 dans la vidéo de ta vidéo
bah oui bah moi j'ai joué ses premiers
championnats du monde jeunes des
championnats du monde des moins de dix
ans 92 je jouais scandinave la variante
d'eric prier l'amd si ce nom là bas 5 20
oui jouer un jour scandinave d'ailleurs
et la presse aussi qui était qui jouer
tout le temps scandinaves et on a marqué
plein de points avec sa grâce a pris
jusqu'à un certain moment où tu peux
plus faire mais oui là pour resserrer à
ce large hausse à ben oui j'ai joué
contre contre gries chouk le cadre des 5
la variante avec calais c'est si ces
cavaliers m6 oula ça joue vite là oui
mais c'est un visage ou pis car il agit
nous rappelle alors pardon on reprend
sur ils ont joué très vite maxime a déjà
joué ça je crois contre moi ils
s'appellent ce jour contre glen hourra
ah oui bon joueur d'ailleurs mis les
doigts hongrois ouais ouais il était
jeune il a battu je crois qu'à 16 ans il
a battu vichy à gibraltar
c'est comme ça qu'on fait on peut
connaître mais là il a bien 26 la plus
que 26 x 26 59 que les droits maintenant
et du coup maxime il a aidé à gagner en
fait de belles parties avec ce genre de
position il a battu
les doigts et bien sûr enfin la plus
connue qui était qui ressemble un peu
mais là on est vraiment dans une
structure qu'il a eue kong les doigts
mais il a joué le même cavalier à 3
contre ding pour stopper sa série ce
terrible c'était 200 et quelques parties
landing il était monté au web c'était
magnifique
c'est plus possible de le régime perdent
pas quoi il fallait il fallait l'arrêter
arrêter cette âme
bon il s'est rattrapé pendant les
candidats du coup c'est quoi le plan
avec les blancs tout bêtement si tu peux
c'est tout rêve de tour f1 et un salaire
très bien pour les noirs parce que les
structures est très bonne et que bon les
en fait maxime à chaque fois qu'il a des
pions doublé en fait c'est pas mal tu te
rappelles ces trois pions ses pions
triplé contre dacca ouais c'était très
bien passé et en fait là c'est plutôt
bien pour les blancs c'est puis en
double et ouais parce qu'il ya la taxe
sur la colonne f
et en plus tu vas jouer des quatre et il
va y avoir du sacrifice des trucs
atteint il fait quoi là ok il défend
avec un fils
voilà un petit des quattro est en fait
la première vraie ouverture de position
ça va complètement le roi est vraiment
faible en fait il peut pas vous gêner le
cavalier 7000 fou 17
parce qu'il peut y avoir son un tour f 5
un petit sacrifice de qualité avec nos
apps sync au bout jusqu'à l'étape 5 et
de l'ouverture des lignes dès que voilà
dès qu'il ya un truc qui va vraiment
s'ouvrira les antilles à cuatro là pour
éviter de l'autre côté
ouais à 4 paraît sympa après un petit un
petit rouage 2 et puis voilà quoi
à 4 ouais c'est en fait là on essaie
d'éviter bp5 fopao maintenant pourquoi
aimez le fond des trois maximus mais je
tâte un cavalier non food et racé moi je
voulais tellement bien je voulais garder
cette diagonale il voulait peut-être pas
les céder 5 mai c'est bizarre
ok foot est roi il n'est pas bien dans
des trains
dollar et par an ces deux comme dans la
partie de ta l'heure où il s'est
retrouvé mal placé pendant toute là il
se reprend la même structure en fait
ouais après c'est je dirais c'est pas
pas si grave mais pour un blitz il est
et il était bien sûr cette grande
diagonale le petit faut donc en fait
c'est les noirs la moyenne de reprendre
un gros truc là allez maximus un petit à
3 laisse à mais non il ya tous ces
cartons plus mais vous ces quatre foot
est roi
oui non mais les kings qui me laisse pas
ce pion prise barouf pas faire deux fois
la même équipe plus mieux pour les
blancs mais c'est pas moins bien donc
lui parce qu'il n'a pas de en fait il a
pas de quoi est fait noir ça va ça peut
répète je pense je pense pas je pense
qu'ils veulent tellement s'envoyer
sentent mettre sur la gueule
ouais mais là on est un peu bloquée
moment quels plans trouvés
j'ai pas après ça peut être aussi
premier qui envoie un plan qui perd
genre d'autres si les noix ou ce we weed
vers le premier qui pousse perd parfois
dans ces trucs là ouais mais je vois pas
comment il peut pousser avec les noirs
il peut mettre ces signaux mais ça
change rien passé sinko peut-être qu'on
pourra même prendre enlever le fou jouer
colonne des noms il part en tournée est
d'ailleurs si de pas mal pour des
risques on a essayé d'organiser un toit
il faut faire attention quand même c'est
de plus en noir ce nom allez non je
pense qu'il est quand même contents de
faire nul avec les avec les morts je
pense c'est vraiment le cas de figure où
tenté de l'a26 tu tentes delà de la
poussette a plus de chance de la perdre
c'est ça c'est ça c'est un comme un gros
1 grosse gang de milieu de jeu quoi
enfin
mais du coup il repart dans ce truc là
allez pourquoi j'ai jamais le bassiste
ou bessette mais ces six dessins que
c'est pas mal encaissé six buts 6 passes
43 et pour moi il me choque à chaque
fois comme je dis à chaque fois il
paraît tellement mal placé puisque
l'acteur surtout qui a et b 4 moi j'aime
bien ces 5
oui c'est bien aussi je dire j'aimais
bien qui a et b 4 parce que finalement
il faut il était encore obligé de donner
le fou avec les blancs sur fond et 2c
s'inquiète un cheval qui revient sur ses
six tués c'est simple tout de suite
c'est très très bien il n'y a pas de
courants d'air là là on peut dire qu'ils
s'élevaient ses phares et en vitesse
serait donc carélie beckham et québec à
tulle a sous le coude à tout moment oui
bah d'ailleurs il va jouer mais qu il
laisse le fou il va reprendre
sinko ça va être pris ça monsieur safa
esprit connaissons la piste à creuser
c'est vrai ya pas une blague
alors est ce que c'est bien pour maxime
de prendre ce pion à celle oui je pense
ben pourquoi pas c'est un pion quand
même mais le connaissait des stores
qu'il allait prendre à tempo très
heureux tu fais quoi je suis guéri ses
six vous prendrez cei d'organiser une
tour en b 8 pour jouer le plan b des
arriérés bah oui en fait parce que même
s'il n'y a pas de pion à 7 en fait on se
fait pas si mais pourquoi que je sais
pas mais pourquoi il n'a pas joué qui a
aidé c'est tout de suite c'est ça qui
m'étonne un peu
ainsi c'est pourquoi aussi ce pour être
vrai que le pion bassin qui était bien
protégé alors attention sur qui a aidé
cette île à quel point ces quatre ans
fouet f3 au québec a laissé six assez
bien
c'est bien les vannes il va vouloir
renvoyer à eux quatre dans l'âge où il
va jouer oued à main et mash up
pourquoi pas cavalier de tess alors
attends qui a aidé cette prise prise
dames 1 on perce opinion way même si
j'ai pas je sais pas pourquoi il n'a pas
joué qu'avec 17 qui avait 17 c'était
très bien
là c'est déjà plus compliqué on va
repères de l'opion mais c'est pas si
grave puisque c'est un pion davance par
contre il faudrait quand même où bon
cavalier 17 ici je pense
ce qui m'embête c'est fou quoi parce que
danton gambie dame variante bas qui il
arrive en 4 le cavaly fait jouer le fou
quelque part et là on peut se retrouver
qu'un fou qui veut vraiment pas ouais
mais bon après tout fait froid qui est
bas je sais mais quand même non mais là
ces attentats le guerrier c3 qui est pas
terrible le f3 qui est pas terrible
toujours un caïd et 7 là le seul coup
qui peut m'embêter c'est fou dès 6 ans
fait la sueur qui est 17 donc keisuke
cats mais il se passe quoi si tu te
prends fou prend g7 fou prend le cadre
damas tu vas ses failles et tu vas jouer
caréné vs fou ouais mais il va mettre le
fou ans et six à sept fois qu'elle prend
ses trois rabbins voilà un magnifique
le cavalier c3 épater les mains dans
cette pause je prends des cinq au pied
voilà je préfère les blancs je suis
désolée pour elle s'est passé un truc
bizarre d un truc qu'on va pas pas
intégrée à l'apu tp non au bizz'art la
bizarre pour bébé voilà sans préemption
b2 je crois qu'il faut les sortir non il
faut les sortir
dans les maquis de quelque chose qu
est-ce qu tine qu'est-ce que tu viennes
à là on est en train de commenter le
truc je sais pas il y en a qui me qui me
parle de poulet je le comprends pas en
fait à elle veut dès qu'on envoie des
200 g
là je pense un doigt directement dans le
chatt légal et 200 grammes elle me parle
de poulet j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas
suivi de paraître 200 g killing c'est
pas ça m'a ça m'a paru complexe el mahdi
poulet kevin je n'ai pas compris
ok ça va avec ces échanges là on dirait
qu'il s'en est sorti on a mis quelques
barbelés quelques 200 grammes et mais
attend il est mieux au temps ouais et
finit tôt je pense qu'il peut plus être
moins bien en fait
et ça va finir à temps mais n'a même pas
depuis au moins cinq ans
mais voilà à tour c'est un bien joué
tourbes et 8 ont trouvé huit bien jouer
votre taille prendre rien et la tourbe
et un tour baie de hawke et drogué mais
s'ajuste droit à
on a loupé ce coup mais bon c'est pas
très sympa les risques et tour à tour b
de nom ouais mais quoique tour à 5 tours
des cinq et il aura cinq ouais non ça va
bien se passer
je suis pas aussi positif que tour à
tour b deux tours à 100 qui à tour
français de tout reprend des cinq ces
trois mois il fait même tout repenser un
airois fuite notre temps du tour 8 f 4 4
avec quatre fils j'aimerais f4f six
tours d1f prend 1,5 to reprend des 5 ou
ff tours 2 il récupère ce pion en c2
c'est ce genre devine que calcule le
ministre et la tour d'autres grands
desseins kroeff cette tour des six tours
pensée 2g 4 n est pas si simple encore
oui parce que j'ai quand même des rêves
et en dix-sept la serre loin pourquoi il
n'a pas fait le fc je sais pas si c'est
relou c'est pas si on loue faut vite
qu'ils jouent tour au dos là je crois
non
qu'est ce que c'est que ce couvre-chef
belle veut pas laisser tout reportage
soit autour c'est sa c2 ah ok mais là je
suis le roi g3 et il est complètement et
en plus il a même ce plan là qui peut se
prendre un petit jouet h si cela faut se
dépêcher lâche 6,3 fuite et tour deux
tours prend ses trois tours 6 voilà il a
trouvé bien jouer maxime leroy g3 là il
ya toujours eu deux par exemple prise
tour des six étapes le pion à vii en
l'air et a pu échec échec pour l' échec
échec et macho donc il a sauvé mais il
faut encore sauver non là ça va oui oui
oui ça va être facile
ok ok la droite pour g6
non mais ça ça pose aucun problème non
oui je n'ai pas dit que ça pose des
problèmes
non non aussi pourquoi donner un pion tu
vois la nasa pose pas problème mais mais
ça fait chier voilà exactement tout
compris kevin ok il la tient mais c'est
relou ce sera cette non ajustées à mais
tout raciste ou réussissent les tours à
4 et là il n'ya pas tout il est urgent
et 700 g 6 bat non non ça va ça non oui
ça va mais ok bref il va y avoir
beaucoup d'échecs là beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'échecs beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'échecs sur walf 600 plus sur
walf saint qui a tout reprend à giroix
g7 veulent tout de suite au caire a tenu
sa fessée la ville mais à combien de
nuits dans ce match c'est que des nuls
quasiment non ouais bah ils défendent
tous les deux défendent bien
c'est des bons défenseurs j'ai
l'impression que balaye encore u2 venu y
avait quoi eu deux victoires il ya eu
deux victoires à maxime une victoire à
l'éval et tout le reste c'était des nuls
donc ça veut dire que le prix d'une
victoire dans ce match est assez élevé 1
voilà ces phrases de mur tu as aussi le
prix d'une victoire important le prix
d'une victoire ça là je suis jamais dit
le prix d'une victoire
le prix d'une victoire ou le prix d'une
défaite
alors ça c'est quand longtemps j'ai
quand même beaucoup rigolé quand j'ai
regardé votre vidéo
s'ils ont les meilleures parties de
moore tacite est vraiment excellent ça
me regarderait faire un plaisir un petit
matin au réveil bad et il ya beaucoup de
vidéos qui sont très sympas mais celle
là je n'avais j'avais jamais vu
j'avais jamais vu celle avec umm orthez
j'ai bien apprécié ma en fait le coût
d'une défaite c'est quoi c'était dans un
open passé sur 6 des premiers ex-aequo
pas là le coup d'une défaite quoi le
prix d'une victoire
non mais tu vois tournoi fermé il ya que
des mêmes des mecs solide
le prix de la défaite est pas le même
nom pourtant c'est parti avec
l'importance à ben ouais mais bon ça
c'est un autre précepte de mur tu as si
tu veux non il ya beaucoup de préceptes
une fois que tu les a tous tu peux
vraiment devenir un bon grand maître
puisque ça tu avais gagné une martin ce
par contre ces deux taxes de vlad t'es
pas bien quoi c'est pourquoi les salades
en fait c'est tes 26 50
pourquoi tu joues quoi va on se sauve en
parfaite avec les préceptes de blattes
paraître les échecs quoi je sais ça y'a
plus il n'y a plus que deux joueurs sur
terre un maximum quoi c'est même ça
chiant d'un autre côté quand on a parlé
au début de mach 1 comment les vannes se
retenait ou pâtes aurait juste dû me
répondre ça pourquoi jouer c'est je
pense que tu aurais pu résumer en une
phrase en fait ah ben oui pourquoi pas
tu dis juste pourquoi es tu balances la
question quoi non seulement comment les
préceptes c'est vrai de vlad et murs
façon complètement
aulas attention et processes qui on
prend ces deux puis on prend baissait
depuis on prend des airs puis on prend à
dimpre en échec car il prend 20 tours
pression avec ses petites ses petits
calculs comme ça très important ça ça
donne quoi sa pression que j'avais en
tête en plus quand c'est parti d'emblée
3 sas et je sais pas c'est dur à évaluer
en fait ça a l'air plutôt qu'est pour
les noirs mais ça c'est pas mieux pour
les noirs attention de pas se prendre un
des cuatro des familles là bas voilà
allez allez ça pourrait il se le prend
et tu peux pas saquer à assilah de l'aga
beaucoup de trucs là c'est mieux pour
les blancs c'est sûr mais à quel point
voilà j'aurai un cavalier j'estime qu'au
ouais c'est pour ça qu'ils jouent des
oeufs
j'avais 15 ans l'attaqué dans la gueule
là il ya tellement de coups il ya
tellement vachement je pense que ans en
vrai je pense que je me lâcherai la la
comme saddam mais j'aimais le problème
c'est ça me manque et je suis c'est ce
que j'allais dire aussi ce soit suite
d'un 8 à kiryat fuite
on donne déposer des lignes beaucoup
trop compliqué pour deluxe mais là c'est
sûr qu'il est beaucoup mieux des six oui
ok mais tu prépares les jours des gens
préparent car haïti beaucoup sur dame b4
d'un b4 parce que là les finales sont
bien pour les noirs dan bekkat tour des
8 mai rouaf 7
bref cette es là tu sac à 85 km 3 way et
puis c'est pas si clair mais bon tu me
diras tu peux même jouer pour trouver du
temps voilà ce qui est bien c'est que
maxime il est bien devant autant et dans
ce genre de position ça peut être très
complexe à la la il a une vraie occase
de faire le premier break du match
ben sasson c'est ce qu'on a
c'est ce qu'on a dit en 5 3 il faisait
déjà la différence autant là normalement
ils devraient
ça devrait être un massacre là un petit
ccim quoi et qu'y des tourbes et si ça
peut être sympa je dis ça d'un beckett
je pense sur ces supports mais là il va
y avoir du sac
il va y avoir du sac de la baignade jeux
ça qu'un temps j'aime bien il ya un coût
de revient ici ces dames des trois as tu
vas tacchella mais après je sais pas si
je me sens mal à issac là oui ça voilà
ça fait mal ah oui il fallait le voir ni
fallait le voir j'ai loupé complot mais
on sentait qu'il y avait un truc mais
c'est vraiment ma testons dessert aussi
trahi la lutte pour un set bien joué
mais peut-être dame de grâce au sort des
quarts et aux 4 barry lane tour à 7,1 ça
c'est sûr mais il était dur à voir tour
à sept mais attendent à mme bessette
alouettes 1 pts et 6 rbds 6 et 6 1
omeyya 2 me 6 tours f4 maintenant ah oui
hanoi à 3,8 0,8 comme g8
on va se présenter en tire une rixe et
l'inspecteur d'ailleurs tiens je crois
que nous sommes une arrestation bien
musclé à temps il ya encore roy 17
hockey mais la gamme hat die à ses 6 par
exemple ces systèmes français 6 dans le
processus
une arrestation bien musclé a énoncé ses
6 3 la glace si vite ça au site us et
adam g 8 3 17 tours des cats est
impossible que ça gagne pas baissés six
ok c'est aussi celle ci c'est le plus
simple 3 david d'amd 6 à 3,8 encore ok
c'est la justice tombe
bravo c'est un maxime des grands jours
ça allait là le plus il fait du bien bas
qui a les faux-pas faut juste pas que
maximis relâche comme il peut en avoir
parfois le débris s'était
pense pas ils méritent de petites fusées
cornavin six états a refusé chat
moi je mets des drapeaux rien sans fil
et je mets des drapeaux bleu blanc rouge
baki je suis pour la double blanc jeu tu
pourrais faire celui du pakistan quand
même ah mais c'est pas mon émeutes
je sais je sais rage mais des petits ol
pour maxime il sera content ouais des
petits ouais ça va des petits ol sa part
ça passe rage mais une rose une seule
une rose pour les commentaires du nord y
en avait une grosse comme ça pour avoir
une rose à temps j'en envoie encore 1 1
j'envoie un super beats superbe l'ex ton
pour max et moi même un petit super
blitz comme ça va on a un petit peu
envoyé à gauche à droite
j'en envoie deux jours n'en vois quatre
pour toi aller à ta vidéo et des quatre
micha quelques heures aujourd'hui
c'était chaud avec micha c'était attendu
aujourd'hui en sueur non je laime bien
en fait mais bon bah oui c'est bien
c'est un peu complexe qua non mais ce
matin je comme comme j'avais beaucoup de
boulot tu vois je pars de chez moi je
voulais je voulais sortir je voulais
sortir une petite demi-heure sans micha
et elle me regarda le sommet devant la
porte elle voit que je m'habille déjà tu
vois je sens un peu qu'elle veut sortir
elle va me chercher une balle elle me
l'envoie à presles me l'envoie devant la
porte vraiment eu à bout d'un moment
j'ai compris qu'il fallait que
j'apprenne quoi bah oui du coup je les
prises mais bon après du coup je
l'apprends et elle court partout fin
assez insupportable à joly qui on prend
fou prend b2 dame prend b2 fou prend 1,4
ouais ça maximy le voir ouais ok désolé
c'est vraiment parce qu'il a posés là il
y est ok je pense que les bonnes
incomplet complète show qui je suis je
suis reparti là-dessus désolé mais
qualificative début 2002 bah ouais ça va
aller elle était très gentille alors oui
normal et très gentil on sait que tu
allais me dire qu'elle ait avait tout
manger tu étais parti un quart d'heure
accepter non non non elle mange
réellement
mais bon là tu vois là avec quand elle
tu apportes la balle et où tu tombes et
nous c'est pareil c'est tendu par trois
minutes
elle rentre pas l'impression que ça fait
4 heures que tu es parti quoi et c'est
terrible elle est sympa nous quitte à
réussir mais j'adorais quand tu arrives
à la photo elle était sur le canapé quoi
c'est exceptionnel la faute au film ce
qui attend secondes de retard sur un
cavalier ses 5 et d 3 là non c'est fini
kessé 5-fu pranger savoie les rois prend
et dames f6 et d'hommes b2 pas sûr mais
la grille qui est force presque s4 aller
la forêt que le ministre se présente
dans celle là là il peut faire le vrai
break à trois points tu fais un prof la
dre les dames prend 3 il a tout calcul à
maxime haut sur dame de il a damé ici
d'amd un échec et f2 prix d'achat mais
l'autre va reprendre ses droits quand
j'ai cette dame 31 01 37
et puis on prend 1,4 sur harry n'ont pas
tenu la rai est dupe le train oui
d'apprendre et un roi prendre c'est la
fusion club leucate vous prend 1,4 à
baisser la devise est magnifique j'ai eu
très peur ils très peur non mais il
avait vu au 10 octobre auquel un
cavalier m2 et comprend bien ok allez f2
qui avait prochain
c'est bien joué quand même j'ai 4 way we
caïazzo qui allait prendre un chien
c'est sûr que là il ya trop d'avancé en
fait en développement où jeff gf3 f1 ok
même ça mais là tous les coups pour os
invoquée mais attend il va même reperdu
lecavalier et non parce que tout le
monde mangeait deux points c'est fini
tôt et deux tours et une tour et deux
pions deux fauves c'est une grosse
différence mais là tu peux faire tourner
8 c sur rage et de ta came tour de ne
peut pas bien jouer mais là où c'est net
avantage on l'adulé
le match ses gammes j'espère un faux pas
faut qu'ils la gagnent s'ils gagnent ce
cas là il est bien il n'y a pas un petit
tour à 8 tours machin il y aura h 3o ya
pas un des signes qu en moi cd single je
réfléchis pas je j'avance le pion on va
tout de suite voir ici qu'aux salaires
fin non non plus c'est terrible parce
qu'après roigé 2 to run tu vois ça va
être dur ailleurs aller manger le truc
tu as tu vas repère les clients la barre
les les chevaux en finale c'est là ils
n'ont pas de case ok ils essaient de
trouver une case là des cuatro bon tour
gesing hockey les toura schmid qui
arrive tour justine coquillages trois
points qui laissent hockey même il veut
tour à chute aura tourné dos
ouais ouais tour g5 c'est pas tout à
jeter l'épongé cinq sièges préfère étant
assez oui mais là c'est ok c'est
tellement de matériel davance mais ouais
mais bac il faut se méfier oui il faut
se méfier un petit peu c'est bien ce
truc gémit ans son dernier coup la tour
3 détroit qui jouait ces six un peu
hockey avait plus propre à faire quoi
ouais mais bon il lui laisse le coup tu
es locaux
j'aime bien j'aime bien laisser les
coûts aussi dans ces trois peut-être
mais le cavalier qui vient à eux deux ok
tour ces deux courses il va les
rechercher à dos en plus ils peuvent pas
faire cours des doigts si à tour à tour
ses uno ou lâches qui reliait phase iii
magnifique
ok c'est peut-être un joli coup mais bon
c'est peut-être le meilleur coup parce
qu'il veut aller chercher le cavalier en
force quoi mais bon je regarde le temps
tu vas après 1,3 g de 13,5 j'aimais bien
tu vois tours fc a croisé deux tours ces
deux rois princes où la tour d2 il pense
qu'il peut
ils se contorsionnent 1 mais je vous dis
là jouent bien regarde il va récupérer
le pion il va pas avoir perdu à deux il
va faire tournoyer la whey mais tu vois
c'est terrible parce que là ok max il a
fait le pire et pourtant c'est encore
complètement gagnée haut parce que voilà
parce que c'est des choux gras
car les deux il bat marois gbagbo a donc
imaginé ici il fait 26 me il montre la
différence dans la finale entre entre
les chevaux elle a tour à tour et j'ai
deux c'est plutôt bien joué par contre
il faut échanger cette tour ok c'est
bien épicée voilà finito eyefinity
complètement fini tôt il va il va
récupérer les 3 enfin le tour bien de
mario pour faire tomber non plus trois
plus trois baky enfin ouais bah il a
fait une bonne partie là il a fait deux
bonnes parties cet homme est une fusée
et tu peux pas envoyer de fusée que
cette terrine je peux pas enlever le
sujet ici j'ai pas terrible allez ça va
la plus +3 allez faut appuyer bac il
faut pas faut pas se relâcher la folie
mettre la tête sous l'eau oui c'est
important pour la madgi d'après de
continuer à bien jouer il faut tenir la
distance
nan nan faut tenir la distance et puis
il faut faut s'assurer d'un bon retour
de l'even qui peut quand même être
dangereux en bas qui je le rappelle mais
c'est ma position tout le maximum qui
peut être dangereux il peut être dans
maxim pas dangereux pour lui-même il
peut sortir du match perdre deux parties
loterie revenir à un point et après il
pleut il peut être mettre le turbo à
rien tu sais pas un moment donné ouais
ouais et puis peut y avoir une problème
de court
non il faut il faut rester à +3 à les
antiques et alliages quattro la sillage
quattro qu'il faut faire médecine puis à
l'euro de tout 3150 aussi bas qui il ya
quand même plusieurs choisi siens ouais
les road c'est quand même important
ouais bah oui khalaf ont profité 3100
3070 c'est beaucoup et c'est bien pour
ça que je dis ça il ya d'autres choses
en juin qu'il ya plus qu un speech
haïtien je lui ai demandé de planter le
drapeau quand même 1 3150
h3 carélie g4 non j'aime bien qu'il
réagit cultissime blitz menace cavalli
absinthe avec l'it et sur cavaliers la
vie république et si ils évitent scouts
a aussi dû être de f4 à maxime qui joue
trop dans le centre qui a oublié qu'elle
allait prendre quattro j'avais demandé
il se passe quoi dessus il a vraiment
bien je pense mais ça rappe ten dam des
trois est peut-être bon ça ok des cuatro
avec la tour ans et 8 maxime ne faut pas
de show il peut avoir des baisses de
régime
oui après il a quand même toutes les
pièces qu'ils sont bien placés pour
jouer des cuatro
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être un bon coup
qu'ils allaient prendre quatre dames des
trois cavaliers bouche de dieu tu peut
même manger b5 pour manger le 5 mai je
pense qu'avec un coup simple comme
cavalier h4 il est ce que tu dirais que
mieux que maxime c'est un joueur qui
joue beaucoup à l'énergie
oui bah ça ce mois faillit pas forcément
tu joues beaucoup à des régimes qui se
sont en fait tous qui a besoin d'être
concentré quoi il a besoin d'être dedans
pour bien jouer je te sors toutes les
expressions demi-heure pasqua jouer à
l'énergie et tout quoi bah ouais mais tu
as des joueurs comme ça il a besoin
d'être impliqué plutôt que de l'énergie
il a besoin d'énergie pour être impliqué
on va récupérer 1,5
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je vois
pour s'entraîner pour lui les road c'est
très bien parce que je joue pour quelque
chose il ne peut pas jouer tout seul
sans moi je sais je suis un peu pour ça
qu on les organise avant les matches et
youtube on se met d'accord et où on
essaye de faire mais pourquoi moi je
peux je suis plus enclin à jouer à
pouvoir jouer tout seul en fait c'est
pareil auquel jouent les road c'est même
plus compliqué quoi on va discuter tout
après c'est cool
mais maxime celle inverse mais maxime
c'est complètement l'inversé peut juste
pas joué pour rien quoi toi il peut pas
jouer pour vraiment pourquoi tu joues
filles se demande qui se demandent déjà
pourquoi il joue en général mais merci
encore là tu vois des jeunes là il a du
mal c'est déjà pourquoi il joue là en ce
moment là le match est fini tôt toi et
puis voilà ok c'est pas normal ça je
peux pas te laisser remonter comme ça et
puis surtout que c'est en pensant comme
ça que du coup le match n'est pas fini
tant parce qu'il suffit que le magazine
de jean il est la voix c'est exactement
ça c'est exactement le pourquoi tu
défends il se demande pourquoi il joue
là ils jouent pour rien ça me gave
ils ont des coûts je descends micoud bon
il reste quand même bien plus fort que
les vannes mairie des mées oui ça se
comprend
c'est ici ou là bref trois tu vois c'est
chiant là il se prend h55 h4 ça va donc
et c'est louche qui est un petit peu tu
vois ok il va fermer le bien sûr mais
c'est lui qui me gêne pas oh la la
tension d'amd 5 qu'est ce qui se passe
dans le dessin qui avait tout rose
regardez ce joli coup pour prendre 20
d'emprunter 5
c'est une déviation donc dames 1 c'était
joli parce qu'ils gardent ils menaçaient
tour des huit et orages suite matt
gagerais damas propose la dame a bien
joué mais c'était magnifique
il reste combien de temps dans ce petit
match il reste longtemps encore en
réalité reste 26 minutes le 5 puis ça
m'a paru passé très vite alors que le 3
puis 5
bah disons que comme le match il était
quand même plus serré c'était plus
j'étais content de voir plus de dix
minutes parce qu'en fait en bullet même
si t'es pas trop concerné tant perrin tu
te remets tout de suite donnant trois
mois il va être plus vicieux en fait
ouais
l'olympus en fait tu joues quoi fin ça
ne t'a pas le temps en tenant les
pourquoi veux tu joues en fait c'est que
c'est clair on dit tu peux pas jouer la
montre quand tu es devant comme ça bat
pas encore là il ya passé mais car
clermont temps encore
la maxime qui fait pas une énorme énorme
star parce que ce genre de positions en
blitz et quel plus facile à jouer à
jouer pour les blancs est les attaques
qui arrive vite les bat on voit les
chevaux s3 et g iii le phocéen qui déjà
même sur sa case il est déjà sur le roi
le four b3 qui arrive en c2 qui aussi
sur le roi cdd position il faut être
très très précis au noir d'ailleurs tu
vois c'est la première fois que maxime
est en souffrance autant et en vraie
souffrance en plus fort heureusement
qu'ils mais y met un cheval sur sa case
mais bon fous ces deux cas les à cinq
n'a pas trop de n'a pas trop d'idées à
part faire plaisir à un maxime gremetz
est pas mal il défend avec le cavalier
fuite là qui rentrent qui vient protéger
un peu ce roi qui était un peu tout seul
quoi peut-être pas tout de suite qu'à
lire fuite mais c'est un bon c'est un
super défenseur c'est surtout pas pour
jouer un coup comme fois fuite ou la
hausse avec la sagem pas du tout ça
c'est horrible où le cavalier au
lecavalier au jeu vous là on est ces
séismes en times voilà bien là on n'est
pas bien mais bon ok après fois qu'il
faut qu'ils gagnent quand même
fondée 3 face à lebron c'est un peu
c'est ces petits pains quoi bon après tu
sais c'était plus un joueur de descartes
donc ces postes d'espagnol c'est pendant
que son truc
mais las de voir un jouet un x 8 pour
mettre un cheval bessette paris van
zandbeek agents qui étaient là et se
prendre b4 après ouais c'est magnifique
ou pas j'ai presque envie de prendre une
photo en oeuvre d'art de de maximus
ouais après risque ouais non mais après
c'est pas il faut la gagner avec les
locaux quand même pas mais il est quand
même pas bien non il est pas bien fois
ci c'est yves à sac
cette qualité je pense voilà c'est quand
même catastrophique ça me rappelle les
paras il abandonne 4 rappelle les plus
belles parties de krikor j'envoyais des
roses
j'envoie des mongols imposteur ah oui là
c'est faux c'était pas la fusée il ya
plus de plus de pâtir c'est ce dont on
parle et c'est en fait il sort du maquis
fait une mauvaise paraît-il autant fait
une bonne ilâha illâ un point non mais
en fait ce qui est bien c'est que la
partie était tellement mauvaise que qui
va se remettre tout de suite dedans en
fait ça l'était pas avec toi tu vois
c'est pas comme si tu fais deux trois
parties campaient runes à la limite et
que tartuffe et 2 3 nuls temps repéré
une non c'est vraiment a vraiment tout
donné dans celle là quoi et ouais après
nom fut si l'eau il n'a pas encore
besoin de jouer la montre un maximum pas
du tout donc mais pas encore de toute
façon bas il peut pas et puis ça oui
voilà c'est pas ça sert à rien comme
l'ail et joue la montre quand tu peux te
faire remonter ou quand est moins forte
que dans adversaires ou des trucs comme
ça
là il joue juste mieux il a juste fait
une partie vraiment
ok disons que c'est comme un mish clip
quoi surtout le match c'est pas grave
après la montre il pourra ainsi à plus 2
à 5 minutes et que on est en plus un
allawi oui bah même en trois plus pour
jouer un petit peu moins s'ils pensent
que c'est qu'il a plus de chances aux
héros
mais bon oui oui mais après ce qui
m'étonne c'est qu'il ait pas rejouer de
ces quattro
non parce qu'ils étaient il était
tellement bien dans cette finale là ils
jouent des des lignes où il a eu quand
même où il appelle quasi rien il va se
faire échanger leurs villas du mario du
tout là il a rien du tout ça il commence
à avoir un minime est fou de cette la
foux 17 et u va les changer demain midi
truc tu vois pas ce qu'il a il a il a
deux meilleurs fou mais c'est vraiment
mini parce que tu peux pas vraiment vous
savez il faut renvoyer ouais ouais c'est
vraiment trop mini annoncé hyper min
donc il reste quoi il reste encore 21
une minute dans ce secteur et après y
aura trente minutes 2 1 + 1 et à la fin
on compte un point complexe pour mieux
tu dis j'ai pas le timing
tiens je me fais un petit break 2
minutes kevin vas-y comme cette partie
en plus à l'est pas hyper passionnante
m'a dit vas-y vas-y oui il a l'air quand
même un peu fatiguée un peu board en
fait sur la sur le vide c'est sur la
vidéo au maximum je sais pas ce que tu
en penses aux élèves prend que 3 qui par
votre publicité sur la tête de maxime
rouquet a tout un kevin et on perd ils
tiennent pour un petit moment la tour
qui vient enfin le fou qui repart
angers7
sarah jouer pour pour le pion à vii les
amis on va voir on va voir ce que ça va
donner
est ce qu'il va pouvoir faire parler à
la colonne pas du coup il fait ses
cadres pour essayer d'ouvrir la
diagonale faut aussi long qu'à et de
deux pions sans trop pour maxime
mais d'un autre côté ils sont difficiles
à avancer peuvent ils sont bloqués par
le pion c6 qui bloquent l'avancée des
cinq le pion des quatre qui est sous
pression et du coup sur e4 adam prend
des quatre et il peut aussi arriver un
coup comme f5 un moment donné 100 cas de
besoin pour vraiment bloqué les pions
avec d'autres pions donc c'est pas si
simple côté côté maxime d'avancé mais
bon il a créé un déséquilibre dans la
position en reprenant de f est
clairement ça va lui permettre de jouer
pour le gain ou pour la défaite
d'ailleurs mais ça permet de mettre de
la vie dans la position là normalement
les bonnes par contre de la dame et
finalement moi je préfère quand même les
noirs parce que les peler psion
n'arrivent pas vraiment avancé et il
peut se prendre peut-être une rupture un
jour cependant ça reste très proche de
l'égalité c'est même probablement égal
et j'ai réussi de même un peu avec avec
ma préférence pour les noirs parce que
hockey maxime a quand même cette idée là
il ya quand même le pion f7 sous
pression tout réussissait bien joué il
place sa tour et il couvre un peu son
pion à vii mais maxime s'organiser
veut faire re 4 il a mis le fond à f2
pour protéger le pion des quatre il va
vouloir envoyer le cadre des 5
les vents qui envoie h5 et probablement
quatre ici qui va partir pour jouer par
la suite des 5 alors pas tout de suite
un joueur par là yaya toure prendre mais
mais sûrement à eux quatre qui va être
préparé d'amd 3 et le 4 pour rejoinder 5
mai réussi à l'empêcher les bonnes je
pensais qu'il arrêts et qu'elle allait
réussir à le à le forcer
mais les bonnes qui s'en sort plutôt
bien et qui met de plus en plus de
pressions à la case the cat est
complètement contrôlé maintenance et
pion aux trois de maxime qui se retrouve
un peu faible la tour qui peut
éventuellement venir un jour en 4 le
pion h4 la dame qui reviendrait à eux
six mois mais après ses solides 1 quand
même mais c'est petit avantage noir
quand même cette histoire mieux autant
aussi qu'au téléphone faudrait pas la
perdre celle là ce serait ce serait
clairement un problème il était terrible
3 ouais ouais il n'est pas il a il à la
baisse de régime la ouais ouais on le
voit on voit sa tête terrible
allez faut qu'ils trouvent le second
souffle allez un petit matelas sur les
cases noires en plus il est mal autant
qu'il n'y a pas de mc do tous rêvent dos
je pensais adams et de et des fois des
idées 2,4 mais tous rêvent de west ham
100.5 et quand même far away pas bougé
cette rue ok bon ça va il va la tenir
quand même bon il ya quelques âmes ya un
marchandage possible à tout prendre on
apprend tour ces deux sites ours et 6 6
1 4
allait-on vous allez tour c6 attend si
ce n'est qu'un drame quatre des cinq
tours être f6 un loupé tour m2 tour à
deux coups pour coups
kurram sept ouais mais sûrement gros et
j'ai de l'amour a g6 attends tu peux
faire h4 ouais ouais ouais c'est ça doit
gagner du coup faut qu'il joue n'importe
quel coût l'aller
dames e cape à damas quatre des cinq
hommes qu'ils fassent croire g5 ok mais
bon oui bon ça c'est trop dire avec non
ouais c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle ou
plutôt une bonne nouvelle ou là
réussissent ils à jour
wang draw d'euros dont il respirait 16
minutes à ya pas besoin de faire de pub
cacher un pour les bac b a fait un bond
les envoie directement
il joue plus avec eux si ce parce qu'il
avait eu des problèmes sur cette
ouverture qui est il
il a bien fait de changer elle n'a pas
été bien à la précédente nul malgré
l'eau de compass eddy renard et ses
finales de tourelles sont complètement
nul
c'est qu'il ya tant la dispo dès wenger
pour commander le mag mais ils sont
dispo là non ouais je crois on me dit
son son semi dispo
mais ce midi sport ça veut dire quoi en
fait genre cerise
si je vais sur le site je peux les
acheter ou pas ouais ouais on voit quand
on peut aya du délai sont achetables
maintenant ils sont achetés parce qu'il
ya eu tellement de réseaux là on
commence ça commence à partir ils
pensaient qu'ils se mit dix mois s'avère
qu'il ya des gens qui en ont quelques
partenaires ça pourrait chauffer une
partie brousse avec avec domingo y
aurait moyen d'organiser un v1 domingo
qui était qui ceux qui s'entraînent ya
peut-être un bon en vue ils ont le même
niveau en fait sont tous les 2100
surface comme ça peut être serré ce qu
elle serait ça peut être pas si ça peut
se fermer mais c'est marrant quoi
d'avoir exactement le cema road to lvl
c'est marrant c'est exactement le ils
ont exactement le même niveau quoi sert
à tout l'adie m'a dit que c'était génial
quand tu quand tu réussissais à trouver
ton adversaire en blitz à l'époque
bah ouais mais même aux échecs en
général oui il m'a dit quand tu trouves
un cadre vraiment on yvonne dit c'est
génial c'est davantage du jeu surtout
quand on commence en même temps ou quand
on trouve quelqu'un de son niveau c'est
vraiment le truc vraiment parfait quoi
ouais c'est génial ou sinon après il
faut trouver des moyens toi c'est un peu
comme logo
quand tu joues tu joues à la maison avec
quelqu'un on retrouve et de l'endroit où
c'est vraiment pas clair où c'est
vraiment à la limite go tu donnes des
pions davance le mot échec retrouver la
même chose mais quand le mieux c'est de
trouver quelqu'un de son niveau mais
j'ai raconté l'histoire de vlad et du
goban chez lui pas sûr non pas sur la
plaza va acheter un global on s'était
mis au go et on s'est tellement
intéresse le truc il avait acheté 1 go
bad ont essayé de jouer de temps en
temps en garder un peu des trucs et on
s'y intéresse
mais à un moment donné enfin cgg
l'histoire un jour plus de go bad deux
jours plus de goban trois jours plus de
goban jablah des ans une petite partie
de go machin et toute leur magie et mon
petit go 5 sur 5 sur 5 ou 9 sur 9 g +
machin non je pas très envie de jouer
tout je vais chez lui il ya plus le
covan
et jeudi mais la douce gobain évident
mais je jouais il avait son ex femme
elle m'a battue j'ai arrêté quoi j'ai
racheté le jeu quoi il avait vendu une
partie contre son ex femme est il
arrache quitte le jour dans l'exposé aux
échecs qui à 2660 il demande pourquoi tu
joues et la garde une partie quoi mais
je ne veux plus voir ça mérite le mérite
de mettre quelqu'un vlad dans le nord le
chat coincé dans quel conseil s'il a dit
cette célèbre phrase pourquoi tu joues
diffusera en fait il parlait de ses
potes qui était grand mais très
professionnel et qui n'ont pas de gagner
deux tournois depuis 3 ans et 10 qui les
appelle au téléphone et qui leur
demandent pourquoi tu choukoud l'essor
du goba d exceptionnel qua non pas de
quoi est fait pour qu'on joue plus au
coach qui ont joué ont joué vraiment
quoi on s'était intéressé au jeu et tout
est en fait tout d'un coup je vois le
stop a été un peu sévère qu elle vit qui
se passe ouais et puis en plus à ses
collègues il dit ça mais vraiment je
pense que nice a vraiment sérieusement a
très clairement il ça sérieusement oui
oui c'est pas du troll ans est un ancien
du tremblement non non il est sérieux
d'ailleurs lui l'a arrêté en fait il
s'est posé la question il a répondu mais
voilà maintenant cette ouverture maxime
moi je peux pas vraiment dire de nom et
tout parce que ce serait pas correct par
rapport aux autres grands maîtres mais
il m'a dit quand tu gagnes pas une
partie facilement contre intel à quoi ça
sert même de venir s'asseoir quoi faire
quand tu peux quand tu gagnes plus
facilement avec les mains contre d'etel
pourquoi tu jouais vraiment quoi tu
comprends qu'ils vivent
alalalala maxime ou la pas dans son
assiette maxime mais ça non ou à refaire
pourquoi t'es inquiet je suis pas
inquiet mais il ya dix minutes où nous
dit le match est fini lattaquié bah
ouais mais il se fait choper autant il
se fait choper dans les positions voilà
tu as peur tu as peur qu'il ya un
accident à la prendre à trois il va
revenir en a 7 ans je pense qu'on est un
peu des barbelés la voile et ouais ouais
il m'aidait à lui l'aimé lui même sur
son roi mais il a besoin de nous on a
besoin d'autres pas se prendre un f5
sauvage ou 1,45 sauvage one
bref faut mettre les barbelés quoi il
faut mettre les humains cavagnan f5 et
mais ben ouais c'est horrible ouais mais
là je sais une cote tu fais quoi
il est pas bien max là non parce que là
tu peux vite te prendre un cavalier
appsync auger quattro et le fou le fouet
bessette
il joue pas mais ça on a l'habitude de
pièces pareil ok il peut vite aller voir
si ce toit des maisons a que [ __ ] en
bessin que marleau faut qu'on arrive
cinq je pense qu'il veut non bref
kadhafi 6 ils passent par là d'alger
quattro qui fait très très mal à ça fait
mal il menace f6 et sur pions prendre
dame prend il voudra à cavalière quatre
îles menacées rien mais attend le
cavalier tient tous et sur dame prend
donné que valeo 6 échecs et dames précis
ce qui est prévu si ça allait pas de
même 6 2 3 6 heureusement il agit 3 way
toujours dames 1re saint qui a toujours
que j'avais pas vu comme ça mais à ok
ces pièces de moins mais c'est hyper
chaud c'était hyper chaud en fait c'est
toujours pareil c'est toujours chaud
parce qu'il ya du tour ces 2 du wpt m et
cavalli
tous rêvent de eyes toit et la loupe et
tous vos tracts ville alors à terre et
ne sais pas il n'ya pas tombé huit dames
g8 ouais c'est fini mais est ce que tu
peux vérifier c'est toi je peux dire que
je peux te dire attends il me faut juste
une seconde présentation à partir non
elle est tombée 8 de toute façon mais
c'était chaud
or pour des vies tout jamais trouvé ça
et sinon c'est d'arriver 4 mais ok ça
c'est que ce truc là bas c'était pas
clair
oui il a raté tous rêvent de il est pas
bien max non il ya plus qu'un point
d'écart
baky et pourquoi ils continuent de jouer
cette ouverture en plus c'est terrible
les trouve pas pourquoi je vous passe
les quatre veut dire deux joueuses fait
quatre mais là il est il est pas bien
regardé les mises il est très mal là où
il est et à balles de match était fini
voilà il voulait aller se coucher ou
aller jouer à hautmont gosses ou je sais
pas ouvrir à batailler ah non il a l'air
tellement mal là où ça se voit à la
baisse de régime est terrible ici c'est
terrible orage les là elle n'a pas une
bonne tête un nom
alors est-ce qu'il peut récupérer
pendant la pause ou pas ça la question
bah ouais je pense qu'il va twilight
devrait dire ok je vais il reste combien
de temps cette minute répète avant cette
partie là ils auraient dû mettre sur
pause et dire que je vous dois être quoi
il va se faire un café et puis c'était
le moment
non là il n'a pas l'air bien
il n'arrive pas à faire ce à quoi ils
devraient faire des trucs de mar où un
petit peu comme ça comme tout le monde
voilà un traité c'est ce qui fait le
charme de maxime aux siens de pas ouais
mais bon là tu vois qu'il est ok quand
tu es dans un état pareil tu prends
pourquoi les autres le font ils pas vu
quoi ouais je sais mais je pense qu'il
aimerait que personne ne fasse en fait
bah ouais bah voir le problème c'est que
c'est pas le cas je sais bien etienne
mais je veux dire j'ai du mal à le
critiquer pour un truc où aller ce
projet oui bah oui il est trop gentil le
patron oui mais bon c'est difficile de
critiquer un gars parce qu'il est gentil
quoi pour le f4 qui marchait pas mais
qui était jolie quand même la casse le
double clouage parler alors ici ça
ressemble à pas si mal pour les blancs
mais attention aux attaques avec le
cavalier qui peut vite arriver à 4 et le
roi est assez faible
le roi blanc est assez faible en fait il
faut faire attention à m6 assez content
pour moi ça gérer encore évalué 5 et
j'ai trois noms même si c'est un mauvais
coup il devait jouer aux dames elles six
courses il est un peu violent à la maman
il a mis à m6 est clairement une fois
autant c'est pas g3
j'ai trois cavaliers au set c'est pas
sûr qu'il soit mieux en fait enfin qu'il
soit vraiment venu à damas cat c'est
joli sur cavaliers cette prise et f4 et
ghadames c5 ou même donc peut-être
cavaliers des quatre noms auxquels on
prend un cavalier au cices
qui est des quatre intéressant peut-être
je sais pas
les quatre complexes que son ca marche
c'est bien toi son existence là devant
l'ordi si j'ai un petit coup d'ordi pour
ce qui est des quatre numéros on leur
dit non merci ça marche très fort en je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'il a joué
dans vos 4 on va voir s'il est en forme
et il ne trouve pas ça c'est
définitivement inquiétant ouais bah oui
c'est bon ça je t'ai dit doit se lever
ça sert à quoi de faire seule c'est
terrible heureusement que c'est bientôt
les bullet anglet savaient début c'est
un changement de rythme en fait un petit
quart d'heure un petit 10 minutes tu te
lèves tu vas prendre l'air là il faut
qu'il faut on sent les moments où faut
prendre l'air ou pas prendre la dame
sait d'où il se prend kébé 7 qui
essaient 5 probablement ice commence à
être moins bien alors que kery des
gâteries la barre net avantage voire
même car ali prend vista est au pire tu
trouves pas nuls là oui il ya torah 5 au
sila qui est intéressant au plan les
noirs le tour à cinq a peut-être du bec
ou accro au f5 ça c'est plutôt pas mal
joué c'est simple je pense ça va les
problèmes sont soulevés mais je pense
que nul serait un bon résultat ici en
fait ben maintenant ça devient déjà ok
c'est complètement qui est pour les
blancs limite jouable je dirais même vu
ses coûts mais je préférerais que ça se
finisse parce qu'il est toujours à plus
1 c'est ça ouais
attention roi quand même attention roi
un tour à tour des six tours g6 je sais
pas quoi là qui qui peut vite
ouais mais dans mais attention quand
même quoi
y'a pas de quoi trop là tu vois un truc
comme ça non tordre et attendez c'est
pas madame c'est ça tu veux tordre et ça
a été a joué le tout pour le tout d'un
point quatre jours ils espèrent une
meilleure finale la maxime
mais je pense qu'il aura pas de finale
là là ça sent le tour j'ai six sur le
tour en dessins que c'est une bonne
nouvelle très bonne nouvelle
est ce qu'il est une trame c4 à tordères
attention ce cas n'y aurait peut-être
pas mais c'est chaud hein
il reste vingt ans dans la cadence il
reste devrait donc y aura encore une
partie derrière normalement à moins que
ça la dure 40 coups encore ce qui est
possible
donne b3 c'est pas si mal ou là il n'y a
pas à quatre places et 5 c il n'y a pas
dû à 4 à 5 sauvage à 6 à 7 pour partir
là un yvan colonna dans le 3 c'est pas
mal là en fait cette vie au mieux pour
les blancs quand même attention quand
même hyper rare du f4 qui part à tout
moment à 4 bien joué là la position du
roi finalement elle est devenue tout va
mieux pour les blancs
c'est très très important et ans avec
peu de temps comme ça c'est vraiment
primordial ouais parce que la première
en gloire ou kerouac 7 c'est plutôt un
bon coup la première erreur noire elle
est décisive des jeux à la tour qui
vient hanter 3 à quai à perdre est un
effet nul d'accord ok oui donc en
dessous c'est pas si mal de faire sept
pour bas ce qui est bien c'est qu'ils
s'assurent de démarrer les bulles est a
minima égalité quoi romantisme ne pas
commencer derrière il en reste une
tu fais tu débutes aille plus un mais
pression il sait qu'il est pas bien il
se connaît maximin
attention un paquet prend 1,4 à damas
quatre ça c'est un piège typique
d'ailleurs les blancs peuvent le faire
avec le four deux rouleront plaisir face
où ça peut marshall et j'ai six coups g7
petit rock cavaliers b 17e cinq jours
nouveau 5 voilà genoux des cinq après
non c'est pas la prépa des candidats
mais c'est s'aider coup maxime esque
mais presque et la prépa des candidats
et pas que et pas que non mais ça c'est
des coups qui montre qu'il est qu'il est
dedans parce que c'est des pauvres voilà
des coups faciles si je les ai dit en
même temps c'est que c'est pas des coups
difficiles mais ces décos assez actif
quand même faire gaffe car un espace
prendre du tour d'un christ et 4 allée
van leeuwen à la caméra là il y reprend
du poil de la bête de ou fin et les
candidats derya toujours pas de date
précise et on est d'accord on est
toujours sûr printemps 2021 bah oui bon
après un temps 2021 ça veut dire ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire attends c'est
quoi ce sera peut servir les figues mars
je pense je pense qu'ils vont ils vont
faire la reprise pile un an après le
truc ça serait ainsi dans 21 secteurs
non mais scène s'est terminée le 24 mars
non 25 25 ouais mais bon alors là c'est
vraiment début printemps quand vas tu
appelles ça printemps oui oui mais j'ai
en fait qu'ils appellent printemps et
sépia pas aucune précision quoi wifi et
je pense que ce sera début printemps et
ça serait drôle en fait qu'il reprenne
pile un an tu vois après ça serait je
pense ça serait une belle
quand je bois je pensais ça non mais
c'était pour meilleur mais
officiellement il n'ya pas plus
d'informations que printemps mais ça
sera ça sera début du printemps ça c'est
clair ça sera pas tu vas pas mais bien
avril mais bon ouais fin mars début
avril ça dépend où on sait toute façon
ça va bientôt on va bientôt être au
courant parce que si jouant
en fin mars j'imagine que mi-janvier
vous aurez les dates paraît que tout le
monde alors je crois qu'ils ont dit que
qui est début janvier
ils donnent ils allaient tu peux tu vas
y vont pas communiqué les mâles et date
le 25 février pour dire les candidats
reprennent le 22 mars à horizon 10 ils
ont dit on fait ça début de l'année je
crois il y donne donne les dates début
de l'année et voilà après avoir commencé
à organiser un petit vont obliger de le
vaccin en quoi on verra bien c'est
encore une autre question est-ce que
vlad est vacciné du coup j'ai pas faut
que je le rappelle mais en fait il
comptait 1 se faire vacciner
en russie la campagne de vaccination
elle a commencé où elle était en train
de commencer je passais à la commencer
ce qu'ils ont réussi les militaires je
suis pas ils sont maxime et vague de
jamas de monde à ma femme à ce monde
mas 2
oui c'est soit militaires médecins
machin est tout ouïe médecins sur le
tard voilà qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de
gens qui sont actifs et un beaucoup de
gens auxquels j'ai pas c'est aujourd'hui
j'ai pas les références
est ce que est ce qu'on peut est-ce
qu'on peut encore voyager en russie
d'ailleurs allé en russie en fait tout
est normal la non mais par exemple est
ce que demain au dessus parce qu'avec
senna oui mais pour faire un visa tu
peux pas faire de visa en ce moment
d'accord donc tu veux toi tu peux pas
rester avec un visage aurait pu oui mais
là tu peux pas d'accord oui donc même
toi tu peux pas y aller en ce moment
toujours pas alors moi en fait
théoriquement je suis dans les seules
personnes qui peuvent y aller dans le
sens où le seul type de visa qui font
c'est un visa de regroupement familial
d'accord moi ayant de la famille là-bas
je peux faire un visa mais c'est juste
parce que je suis marié à une russe en
fait c'est terrible et mon maximum
il est pas très bien
bijoux ils jouent mal un débat depuis
quelques quelques parties à ya rien de
rien porter un nom à dire il est
derrière mais la grande la grosse
question en fait c'est ce qui va se
remettre devant après la pause où est-ce
qu'il va sombrer un parce que sombre est
aussi une possibilité 1 je ne veux pas
t'inquiéter bas qui met à attend il n'y
a pas un fou b4 sauvage
il ya du fric 4 mai - ouais parce que
j'étais en train de regarder
n'allez pas bien phu b3 était pas bien
il vend les yvan colonna là il y en a
deux doubles yvan c'est terrible
qu'apparemment il ya tous ces trois qui
intercepte non alors foutez 3 y avait
des fouets f4 qui renaît à la fin voilà
c'est fini tout est sur celle là je
crois que bah écoute on ne peut pas
avoir un match plus serré 1 et ouais ça
me fait pas plaisir
bizarrement je préférais la dernière
fois vous match serré j'ai fait ça à
jouer mieux quand même on va on va se
mettre tout de suite d'accord et tienne
fait de ces affiches rouges a joué mieux
que ce match là euh ok là sur les trois
dernières tu peux dire merci mais je
vois bien mais jouer pas moins bien que
que fait d'os les vannes était quand
même un peu en dessous et les amis et
les autres qui l'ont pas eue ils ont pas
eu de baisse de régime ait envoyé
vraiment c'est ça non mais oui sur le
disons que maxime était similaire aux
autres sur le sur le début de match est
peut-être les bonnes un petit peu mais
pas un petit peu moins bien mais pas
beaucoup un bien donc 6000 à une grosse
grosse baisse de régime pas d harry mené
trois points et les bonnes sans faire
grand chose il fallait remonter un
excellent parce qu'en partie longue il
les a passées baisse de régime
ouais mais là il s'est déconcentré quoi
peut-être tout simplement et puis ça lag
avait rebondi voilà c'est terrible allez
une petite fourchette quelque part là
c'est ce qu'il cherchait fourchette de
crack ito là haut le petit kerala en h4
parfait on veut une fourchette de crack
ito et bien ça le gamin baky scala qui a
émis un seul mais il revient
regardez on la sent la voix sans tuchan
le carrier f4 foot rois mages sont
maintenant c'est impossible
qu'est-ce qui fait c'est pas possible
qu'est ce qui nous fait maxime tout à
l'heure il essaye pas de gagner l'autre
là ils abandonnent qu'est-ce qui fait
je comprends pas ma qui je sais pas
jean-françois ce qui nous dit il est
saoulé c'est terrible il ya un truc qui
le dérange je sais pas il ya quelque
chose qui va pas écouté tienne ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas je sais pas
ce que c'est mais il ya quelque chose de
pas normal
il ya quelque chose de pas habituel ya
quelque chose de pas normal chez notre
cra quito à moins qu'ils aient eu une
envie pressante d'aller aux toilettes
mais il aurait pu faire l'autre a fait
pause pendant le match il aurait pu
faire la même
j'envoie des 200 g
bon je vais faire de 200 grammes pour le
voilà parce qu'il en a besoin on peut
mettre 200 grammes on peut mettre de la
fusée quand même un peu à du 200 g
surtout ses dépenses important qu'il a
fusé on la mettra après le match mais
c'est important qui ravitaillent les
1200 grammes je mets du mal autant aussi
parce qu'ils vont être mal autant
forcément j'ai un peu des pls
disparaître pour l'autre aussi ai fait
des petites micha et db ap je suis un
petit mélange combien de temps là je
crois que c'est entre six et dix minutes
suis pas exactement c'est quoi leur lots
en bullet maxime 3100 leeuwen 3100 elle
est bonne aussi des 3100 ouais mais
sheily lemon peu comme chez bien il
était vraiment fort l'autre match parce
qu'on avait regardé en direct en fait on
n'avait pas trouvé
j'ai vu le match en direct et j'avais
trouvé qu'il était dangereux en plus un
alors on va voir qui avait raison
je mets des teams industrie ok tu veux
c'est pas le serveur 1 comment ça le
serveur il dit qu'il a des problèmes de
co non je pense pas que ce soit le
serveur j'ai vu sa caméra frisé tu peux
lui dire que j'ai vu sa caméra frisé sur
zoom quand il a été déconnecté d'accord
et que moi j'ai eu zéro problèmes de
connexions serveurs que souvent quand et
surtout qu'on habite dans le même pays
quant à des connexions des problèmes de
connexion à notre serveur généralement
les arts plus ou moins tous mais c'est
vrai il y en a beaucoup qui est latent
mais là j'ai clairement vu sa came frisé
à chaque fois qu'ils étaient des gaulois
pierre 18 de redémarrer le routeur ou
quoi il a le temps non là je suis
vraiment sûr que ça vient de sakho
j'ai fait plus attention comme c'était
maxime c'est ouais ok ça frise c'est ça
qui n'ont qu'à les fois où il a été
déconnecté en rouge sa caméra la femme
frisée
c'est sûr ça j'ai vraiment fais gaffe
comme c'était max j'ai vraiment fais
gaffe
oui
ça j'ai fait extrêmement attention
ok en espérant que c'est très chiant de
jouer du nul quand même dû 3 une
n'importe quelle cadence en fait un
arrêt du 15 plus de ses mémoires le
message est clair la mort que ça
t'arrive en plus on y pense qu'ils
pensent c'est ça le problème c'est que
ça tu rajoutes un parasite en fait
ok de coûts ouais du coup fait lui un
mur de fuser la balle et on fait de la
fusée de la fusée eux à l'aide de la
fusée à fond voilà un petit peu de
fusées on va voir mais ouais non c'est
sûr que c'est sa connexion là
malheureusement d'ailleurs ce camp c'est
que chess quoi ça peut être un peu
embêtant bon allez les gars on reste
quand même bien les fusées sont de
sortie ça doit ça doit pouvoir ça doit
pouvoir marcher et on doit pouvoir
revenir revenir à fond dans le match
ça devrait ça devrait pouvoir le faire
bien pleins de fusée
donc les fusées sont là
bon je vous laisse je vais soumettre les
fusées voir ce qui se passe un peu
inquiet quand même un maximum maxime qui
est pas au mieux
je sais pas quand ça va prendre
exactement
les fusées les fusées sont partout bon
alors là on lance un petit prono ludwig
qui nous met un petit prono est ce que
tu nous enverrait pas un petit un petit
prono maxime qui a perdu 2,1 points
finalement cette section on va voir si 6
s'il se remet ça va vraiment être dans
la tête ça va vraiment jouer dans la
tête à 200%
on va voir s'il en capacité de se
relever si la chute continue des années
de retour
en tout cas il est très heureux à jouer
dans la tête
ces dernières trente minutes du coup ils
ont fait ces lemon qui a gagné nos trois
plus un ouais il a gagné d'un point
finalement puisqu'il a égalisé ils
étaient menés d'un point à 4 je crois
qu'il y avait cinq royal quoi ouais
c'est terrible c'est terrible c'est
dommage qu'il a abandonné la russie
c'est bizarre mais bon il doit est
énervé par la connexion saleina rare que
ça lui a pas vraiment coûté 1 ce
problème de connexion à première vue un
dans le match etienne même si on l'a vu
être déconnecté à 3,4 prise c'était pas
à des moments décisifs un type ans ok il
dira s'il veut mais il pense que ça lui
a coûté un petit peu avec cette façon ça
va forcément coûter en influx nerveux ou
quoi mais géré c'est pas fort c'est pas
toujours tombés au pire moment quoi
oui bon quand il ya eu le tour contre
cavalli et ce n'était pas à cause des
décors un après ok là c'est complètement
perdant mais voici joue quelques coups
quand même on sait jamais je peux faire
cavaler f4 tour des deux fours 3g pas
faim non mais c'est perdre oui c'est
complètement perdre en hockey balle et
maxime alors à temps est-ce que je suis
bien connu tu es sur st
ouais c'est bon ma connexion est correct
kevin aller par fait [ __ ] ta connexion
est parfaite et ne suis toujours pas
fibrés tu es toujours en 4g c'est ça bah
ouais le retour de la kadji un début de
mois
ça revient balle et sa part pas les gens
qui ont près qu'ils ont fait dès là ils
ont lancé des paris cette fois ils ont
fait la prédiction team aronian team mvl
et on voit avec les petits logos qui a
misé sur mv elle qui a misé sur aronian
joola d'attention dérive
attention certains la baisse à partir
avant que maxime l'emportent à un bas
qui par expérience régie qui revient au
bon moment à l as tu reviens au meilleur
des moments ça peut pas être plus serrée
1 là ce sera serré jusqu'au bout de
façon etienne ça dure que trente minutes
de toute façon c'est à dire que 30
minutes
donc il peut pas y avoir là là non et
puis il peut pas y avoir non plus
un 5 0 en début de trucs ou quoi c'est
pas possible
non là là ce sera ce sera forcément
serrée jusque jusqu'à huit minutes de la
fin du match par ailleurs à 2 3 points
maximum
voilà ça va être serré jusqu'au bout
cette fois ci et du coup à temps l'âge
et je vois des trucs je te vois je vois
le truc en double en fait c'est pas
normal
tu vois je vois les deux et chéquiers
ouais d'accord c'est ça je dois
peut-être fermer ça va t'en bouche pas
ok c'est parti je regardais un peu les
cartes des joueurs ce que j'étais étonné
je vois les vannes se dandiner un petit
peu maxima toujours pas la tête des
grands jours mais une victoire valdes
valdes est coincé ouais et puis rien que
de recommencer [ __ ] sein c'est quand
même beaucoup moins longs enfin faut il
n'y a plus rien à penser il faut juste
jouer des coups quoi ouais non la photo
juste envoyé ouais faut accélérer
allez ça va repartir et j'ai vu faire un
petit hochement de tête les deux
j'imagine qu'on leur a dit ça reprend
dans 15 20 secondes
ok je vais voir si je peux voir se fait
ici le quément cela à partir d'une
seconde à l'autre je pense que les deux
premières parties vont être
déterminantes à etienne surtout on a un
all-in de pointe chaîne n 3 faire sur
maxime bien joué bien joué bien jouer sa
part 4 5
qu'est ce qui se passe et sa déco ouais
ouais et je vois sa caméra qui qui frise
hockey ouais ouais nan ça vient ça vient
vraiment de lui un malheureusement
et puis du coup ils râlent c'est
terrible mais quand comment ça se fait
qu'il ya paris réussit pas à avoir une
bonne course je sais pas
parce qu'après on comprend bien qu'il a
essayé de se figurer qu'il a tout fait
pour une bonne cause maximin ça fait
longtemps mais bah ouais mais bon c'est
tout le monde se connecte en même temps
il est qu'il a remonté une heure et 21h
c'est le pic à glace ça s'ouvre à la
caméra il lac de vous fondre et il a
vraiment aller on va espérer que en tout
cas ils jouent tous tempo du coup ouais
je pense que les paris vont être
remboursés je ne crois pas merci alors
voici 6 à cause de la connexion c'est en
bourse est il admis la 20 secondes
d'avancé ouais mais c'est en fait il
compense sa connexion par la vitesse de
jeu mais ça lui empêche parfois de
rentrer en profondeur dans la position
et tout est mieux faire profondeur c'est
une manière de parler d'un truc c'est
qu'il devrait avoir trente secondes
avant ce pas un épuisant mais toujours
c'est très énervant quoi quand on voit
que ok on se dit l'adversaire il en
train de réfléchir et puis non en fait
c'est nous on l'a guéri donc oui et puis
ça donne du temps pour réfléchir
justement aller van der sar vases
communicants en fait le temps que d'en
faire ça va complètement l'énervé
justement ça va être un massacre
voilà en tout cas il joue vite ils
jouent bien là ça a l'air d'être bien
revenu ouais ouais tu me fais pays fait
une belle partie
il fait une belle partie d'un des deux
dans sa marche par six dates des deux
équipes rangées 6 bat et ses 5 kg 6 ça
ressemble à ça marche
il ya peut-être dame g5 encore mépris ce
qui est français il a fait dames 3 aucun
relief 5
ces sauvages cavalli pas sûr que ça
marche c'est pas du tout sûr que ça
marche ça marche
si si ambühl aucun allié français 5e 6
dames et fuite et je vous laisse deviner
le dernier coup et non bim bam profite
pour les pâtes oui de marché 1
mais oui oui ces marchés
bam g63 effet ce qu elle a gagné d'amd
de haies dames d2 oui mais attend et
c'est terrible que ça n est pas tout de
suite mais bon ils envoient les pions
quand même je défends tellement bien
g51j agca fait le taf comme un bon
budget
ouais enfin fait gaffe quand même parce
que lecavalier fuite il défend tout les
cas d'étienne un dangereux
ouais mais bon je pense qu'il va gagner
ça va quand même dix dames g7 hafsi si
adam g6 et yappa f7 puff
adam segal bien jouer autour des 3 way
tournée troyes et tours après moi j'ai
des deux serait le roi qui participent à
la taxe cinq tours g3 3g de menaces
tourage trois malfrats qui veulent
participer le portier l'art est fait du
bien ça ouais elle fait du bien ça
mérite malgré la déconnexion du départ
là qui est qu'il est non il est hélas il
a focus qui a pénalisé aurait là les
hyper focus on va y rigole plus parce
que le match devrait être finie cent
fois depuis longtemps
oui tout le monde a envoyé ses petites
fusées alors là c'est important ou très
important de finir le c'est très
important de prendre deux trois points
d'avance l'a22 c'est que de s'éloigner
un petit peu et de pouvoir jouer avec la
confiance maxime qui à 0 match facile
dans ce speech est si la loi il a eu du
mal contre contre niall difficile aussi
qu'on claironne mais si ça gagne c'est
le plus important il pourrait s'offrir
un joli une jolie demi contre magnus un
week-end à temps mais gagne pas un pion
tranquille a déjà calé pas ici merveille
joue bien là tout le temps oui à la
caméra il est pas content je le vois
bien vous le voyez on est pas content
maxi
non il est pas content du tout non ah
c'est fini les gentils y est c'est fini
la championne
au bout d'un moment faut quand même
arrêter quoi temps des trois tours à des
8 et en attend près de nas pour points 3
tours en d2 allez gentillesse et finira
c'est fini 1 p 6,6 à calais b 3 encore y
tient mais qu'elle aille et b4 aux
avantages noir
il a heureusement à partir maintenant
ouais ouais ça c'est facile à jouer en
plus sur karl i à iv évidemment ils
jouent tout reprend 1,3 la mecque et b3
ou kenza et comme si la nature est vous
prendrez doit il est jugé cinq là c'est
pas possible de faire sans lui ou g5
non non c'est pas il a peint ou la tour
c inquiets 7,4
voilà ce qui a aidé 3 c'est fini
heureusement qu'il a joué tour à ses
seins mais la danse et panache
alors oui mon château a juste à l'est
il est méchant maxime il est méchant
tour 4 elle y prend des capi et prend
des cats f5 tourache quatre fois f6 ça
va gagner mais ça va faire deux à
l'essai bien là à cavalli et si c'est
encore mieux parce qu'en fait sur f5 un
cavalier c6 ou cavaliers au sisqa relief
si c'est un coup génial mais la cac et
prend g4 et ça fait 2 0 et on tient on
tient le bon bout là ouais ouais bon
coup génial hein de maxime
j'ai très très bien joué entendu comme
ça dont corinthians swing salsa et on
respire
allez encore une comme ça non il en faut
il en faut encore une quand même là pour
pour être bien sûr non mais là il est
encore hyper focus c'est fini il ya plus
de gentillesse qui reste focus encore 24
minutes 1 il reste encore du temps quand
même etienne on peut pas lui en vouloir
de jouer méchamment la maxime
il faut qu'ils soient mes chambres voilà
peut être que gentil quand même alors là
il faut qu'ils soient méchants et c'est
primordial et on sentait que son sens
quand bullets allait changer quelques
choses variées qui est des deux pas mal
est-ce qu'il va jouer pour les cavaliers
de thé 5 ou d égalisation carême là de
quoi que j'ai 6 mhz qui avait duré sept
et un peu reste un peu faible
j'ai trois pas mal peut-être peut-être
h4 je sais pas comme des trois ou quatre
quand même mais pour bloquer oui oui
voilà ça va être complètement égal dans
le rap a pris serait mieux
bah parce qu'avec le cavalier des 5 il a
une belle case carrément des cinq mêmes
b4 non je pense qu'il est un peu mis
leur à 8 talent qu'elle a lieu sept en
fait 4 que des mauvaises case qui a pas
de bonnes cases touré vitesse sur bessin
qui prend au quai georges b il va jouer
tour à des rois bon mais ça va aller
blanc sont pas moins bien du tout un bon
cari ces deux ok ça échange damas quatre
à calais b 3 donc ça va les cavaliers se
tient bien ouais cac et cédric elles
trois ces trois jets d'oeufs et puis
j'ai quatre peut-être qu'ils valident
des familles jouent comme ça
ah merde car il y avait fin et oui
j'allais dire bien jouer d'amd honda
madame g 4 mais l'allemande a un coût
bientôt il est prévu que cavalier enfin
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas vu
d'amsterdam franges et 4 allée terrible
salah ouais ouais les terrils après
mouvaux il après vous le cavalier a faim
il a oublié l'idée est bonne et
promouvra cause de la cour
c'est terrible ça après après près
mouftah toujours envie de près moov'in
ça ça peut arriver un quand tu as
vraiment oublier un coup ouais ça fait
mal parce que du coup il revient point
ça redevient très serré etienne je crois
que ce match va vraiment être serré
jusqu'au bout en fait découvrir aux plus
en plus c'est tout mais heureusement il
a joué tout juste 5
heureusement tous mais ce qui n'est pas
dans ses aspects ces carrés aménagé 6
assez tranquille il ya les cases
blanches mais a quand même la paire de
fous plus peur tu vois que ça rejoue
comme en début de com comment trois plus
une fréquente et al qariri que certains
bessette et bah oui oui oui parce que tu
as toutes les pièces là au moins il ya
du jeu ouais y'a du jeu mais
vonn qui a repris du poil de la bête en
il a pas mal joué dans la dernière quand
même le petit coup de réussite mais il y
aura des buts était captée c'est un coup
catastrophique
ouais mais attend il a quand même la
casse c'est sa banque et il revient
c'est simple il revient et il n'a pas
d'accès facile à des cinq les bonnes non
c'est paco roca dc5 c'est presque mieux
pour les noirs américains ici 6 qui a et
b 4 way qui va déprendre cote de dsk et
des trois ou quatre cavaliers c6 même
qu'à détroit donc tour des incas les
procédés jamais pour les nouveaux cas et
ce six tours suite c'est les bonnes qui
va devoir faire nul ici à béthune où
maxime est en tout cas les deux quitté
trois arrêts oui on vote recueilli 5
un petit 2 5e alors à temps les bonnes
places prison et d5 trop des simples way
qui va menacer ici prise et à
s'interroger sur quelle épreuve qu'a
tirée à 5 way to b 14 ans crée la case
non attends tour ces deux trois six et
on prend 1,4 à mais il ya toujours à
saint cloud ok joue moins 5 quand même
effet tous réussissent voilà ça il faut
b4 c'était bien sûr un but la terre mais
tu sais en bullet quand tu revois tes
parties après tu te dis mais j'ai raté
tellement de choses quoi sur pareil mais
ça c'est vraiment un coup à la maxime
bassin loubet bullet c'est ça non ça ne
vient pas tout de suite c'est terrible
on c'est chaud allez je vais maintenant
aller là ça apprend par mme way to c3 ce
garde fou et si c'est bizarre ou là à
tour ses sept tours à 7 mais non là
c'est complexe mais il part avec le roi
temps elle va gagner salanon oui ça
serait gagnant prisé tour et 6,6 g h i à
tour et 6
tout reprendre m6 quand même et
attention
est-ce que c'est complètement gagnant
pourrait l'envoyer pura voilà c'est ça
le problème mais il va monter est-ce qui
va être à l'heure ouais ça défend un
petit peu quand même
ouais peut-être que c'est nul à toi à
sarrazin qui ce roi b3 tour ah ouais
pourquoi il m'a pas mis ce tour derrière
c'est terrible est-ce que c'est gagnant
encore ou pas je ne suis pas sûr at an
avant qui bouge la tour du coup
peut-être danger 6 3 et 5
ok ça ressemble
hayatou rats chiens qui arrive c'est
terrible partons à chances et bien
défendu tour h5 peut-être non au kehrweg
ok tour m6
wen est il trop nuls m'annoncer surnom à
les ramèneront angers7 ramène moi serons
angers7
on va pas prendre de risques ramène au
moins trois ans j'ai cette tournée 5a 5b
jouer c'est bien car c'est beau on
retrouve un peu et maintenant que tati
pqr le plan à repartir la barre et abat
voir ces cinq là là je pense qu'il est
il est à l'heure à quatre reprises 3 à
3,5 g
est-ce qu'il est à l'heure où pas à
trois prises à deux voilà c'est fini
heureusement ouais c'était nul mais
ouais l'échec faisait mal un waf 8 allée
hockey gamme ses gammes
on souffle etienne belle victoire de
notre maxime qui reprend la tête et qui
reprend 1,2 points deux points d'avancé
il refait le break 12 10 et c'est une
partie qui a duré en plus etienne donc
ça veut dire que ya de moins en moins
deux parties dans le match parce que ça
l'a bien durer 5 6 minutes un voile et
puis un autre et qu'il aurait perdu où
il donne la dame quand même
donc s'ils se déconcentre pas ça va
mieux ça va bien se passer bien se
passer
ne t'inquiète pas à leyment etienne plus
que les mots maxime dumont maxi vous
aussi plus que plus de 2 3 victoires et
le match et gagner en fait un là je
pense qu'il doit rester six parties en
gros si messi mais deux points ça
devrait ça devrait terminer le le match
y règne une bonne position
il faut être précis en fait avec les
noirs donc une minute c'est pas facile à
gérer
nadia turki russie sarah 4 il va prendre
l'espace ce que cavalier a pas beaucoup
de bonnes cases donc d'un match 4 que
c'est pas trop la case de la dame quand
même mais bon tu aurais six tours à
grains g7 faut pas avoir peur pour jouer
des coups par aig faut pas avoir peur du
tout même
mais ça passe ça passe pour c'est
peut-être même les noirs qui à terme
peuvent être dangereux à 50 ans le roi
regarde la position du roi noir d'amitié
dans des par les cavaliers à danser
menés 6 attention il ya des faiblesses
chez les noirs
si un petit c'est quoi trop ça
ouais t'as pas peur du duo dame
cavaliers ouais mais le truc c'est que
tu as toi aussi tu as tes avantage dans
cette position ces quatre c'est bien
vrai ouais prisca va déprendre dam des
trois c'est vraiment drôle de 5,3 g 2
par exemple tout sort plus ryan tesink
mais bon non non tu vas pas rendre
agréable dans un petit b 3
voilà c'est des blonds qui pressent le
cavalier à la foux prendre quatre et il
va peut-être faire d'un point 4 avec du
comment s'appelle du père pète mesdames
des cats bien joué mais dame 5
probablement bien jouer les salafis en
plus avec madame des huit dames 7 et
damages fuite
ok bref cette même dame dès cet été
comment cette finale probablement nulle
mais bon bref si ce qui revient et
d'apprendre et cette voix s'élèvent
seynois qui défendent faire gaffe il a
loupé d'apprendre cette épreuve trois
dames france si c'est terrible il gagner
le match
adam baisse adams et si c'était bon mais
bon la petite nul allez je vous prouvera
jouer mais tu vois une longue vie devant
moi
elle fait plaisir car c'est nul ça reste
de pointera 10 minutes etienne mais
suffit de faire un point maintenant je
pense pour maxime non non non il reste
c'est 3000 à les bijoux quand même des
partis assez courte
il lui manque il lui manque deux points
là encore pour gagner tienne il va
falloir que je reprenne mes cours de
maths parce que le truc c'est que si tu
fais une partie qui reste trois secondes
dans le match ça relance une partie qui
se joue là où il n'y en a plus je
pensais qu'il restait un peu moins que
ça t'a pas fait attention et parce que
dans les arénas king par exemple où les
arénas en général en fait si quand le
temps s'écoule en fait ça arrête la
partie alors que la wii dont là c'est je
sais que reprend la salle jusqu'au bout
elle c'était pour la petite précision
allez cette position elle a pas trop
réussi à maxime injuste firme annonce
type de position c'est plutôt les vonn
qui a dominé et ce qui va continuer à 25
5 c'est bizarre mais y'avait fouet trois
plutôt projet 5-fu g5 c'est la bonne
nouvelle
il joue pas très bien à ses positions
note maxime normalement simelane ont
effectivement ce soir en tout cas ce
soir il ne joue pas bien on est d'accord
ces pages 4 et un peu embêtant la page 5
kg 5 il a joué ses quatre albums
jeunesse assémien file en dame
mais vous les x 4 et cavaliers f5 mais
ça fait rien non je sais pas je ne sais
pas j'aime et bien un cavalier h 7 au
lieu de deux tours au système pos non
mais il est pas mal autant 30 secondes
chacun jeudi au collège alors j'aime
bien aux fossettes france 4 mais ça y
est ça tourne
c'est bon là c'est la très très bien
tourner celle là elle n'était pas hyper
maîtrisé mais elle a très bien tourné
ouais faut proches 4 c'est quasiment
gamme attention il ya un fou 17 pas qu'à
la fin ok j'ai loupé c'est pas gamme du
tout ça reste ils restent en jeu les
bonnes ouais mais la position est très
très dur à jouer en pro b blues
certes mais bon quelle idée de lui la
joue pas mal hein il va faire cavalier
seul et 5 pour m6 pourquoi pas tous
merci je loupé quelque chose pour le
football à revenir en b3 c'est chaud à
l'aso devient chaud c'est chaud des deux
côtés c'est bien joué qu'à et ses quatre
avec happy prend des six soit choqué des
six allez allez allez allez complexe
etienne mais c'est plutôt bien
c'est bien joué de la part des deux j'en
ai quelques coups ça joue bien où tout
roule 1 il ya plus de casse pour la dame
s'est tour à tour ses 7 à la fin il fait
très très mal
ok et ça revient oh là là mais mon bac
il a 7 ce match là maxime qui réussit
pas à faire l'écart c'est terrible on
réussit pas à s'éloigner de ceux les
bons qui qui se relève sans arrêt il
porte bien son prénom les bonnes dans ce
match c'était le même rêve bien le voir
disparaître comme dirait vlad s'est
passé un mirage ou cette position avec
tout raté c'est incroyable oui c'est
magnifique donc maxime maxime il est pas
mal il était pas mal dans cette position
ouais mais parce qu'elle est noire c'est
plus dur à jouer avec les noirs en fait
là bas puis 0,4 pour max 48 secondes
qu'elle est je suis sans plus il peut
jouer à 4 la g3 ou h trois cavaliers h2
donc droit au hockey fulham
il veut faire des cinq peut-être way
maxime peut-être pas jouer tous les
meilleurs coups là c'est complexe
ouais bah et des pubs il n'est pas mieux
du tout bien joué de la part de l'evo
pas mon corps un roi g2x 35 quand même
et à padoue kg 4 chez les cadets f4 la
fourchette qui menaçait la fourchette
royal ça échange il va faire permettre
la dame en 4d de 90 4 bien jouer me
décider c4 il va falloir trouver un bon
coup la maxe carénage de cristiano carré
lieu 3 ré max europlace vers 3 c3 aussi
voilà ça joue bien là ça joue très bien
et yen ouais un pion de moi pour max may
hamm et du jeu pas mal de jeu bams et de
il touche le cavale
qui est ours est là pour placer la tour
quoi qu'il arrive même si ça marche pas
sur tours 17 1 tour 8 noms qui peut tour
à tour vite aller tout donne raison
qu'elle gagne price this way roi suite
d'un match cg66 et dames sweet way à
temps froid vii
ah oui mais kate honda ouais ouais ouais
parce qu'en fait on calcule et tout le
reste quoi donc à temps il reste 7 50
il reste trois parties exactement ouais
bah encore il faut encore nous inondent
à plusieurs je mens une win je pense une
ulis assurent ils s'assurent le nul
quand le mur
enfin le nul ne les départage quoi ouais
les quatre allers 4 bullet et une wii
nice assure la gagnant et c'est fini
s'il ya une partie c'est fini on sait
bien ce qu'il a fait là ça doit marcher
ça doit marcher
l'ipod quasi terminé le match mais a
tant matériellement il est quoi il a un
pion de moi non moi ok c'est pas clair
il a pas de bol ça c'était à deux doigts
quoi on connait le doigt alors est-ce
qu'il est quand même mieux ou même pas
il est pas moins bien ça c'est sûr à
100%
il ya beaucoup trop de compans la
compensation sont terribles mais
attention quand même un ouais c'est pas
parce qu'ils se contorsionne là les vols
et pas de bol
pas de bol est fou et quatre pouces et
deux en plus c'était pas terrible
ouais non pas de chance après est-ce
qu'il est moins bien suis même pas sûr
qu'il soit vraiment moins bien et moins
bien peut-être pas mais les perspectives
son côté blanc ouais
je crois que s'il est moins bien
clairement moins bien que c'était
arriverait le terrible c'était
complètement finie ouais c'était
complètement fini mais ça c'est les
aléas du bus latin d'envoi et puis tu
vois ce qui se passe à l'est il faut
bien la défendre mettre les barbelés de
toute façon là c'est quand même dans son
intérêt de faire tourner la pendule
etienne g5
il va jouer pour les 5-6 g5 la voilà la
ce a rejoint un peu casquette pas
terrible aux abords de la halle et il
faut il faut trouver de l'activité et
donc ça va moins bien
ok il faut un but à priser tour g5
maintenant ça va il va récupérer le pion
et saint-just mieux il est juste un peu
mieux et il peut il peut faire tourner
le match en sa faveur il ya en fait eu
des barbelés mais il ya une petite fusée
aussi qui par simple acquis 5 5
ça peut finir le match etienne tours
s'est vite pourquoi pas 500 g 8 qui se
pensent et agissent ils soient et à
laisser tranquille ajoute très
tranquille mais très vite c'est
important c'est un tour j'ai trois noms
est pour mais assez fou c6 la tourache
3g 3g katia eu cinq tours h3 je plie
mais ok je vois pas comment tu t'en sors
la clé avec les blancs faut pas prendre
h4 faut pas prendre h4 kevin faut jouer
mais je savais qu d'abord puis tu prends
h4 ouais ouais ça va ouf
ouais non non c'est ça se passe bien le
roi qui monte maxi va revenir là pour
taper le pion c3 ouais c'est coisy gamme
ça ressemble ça ressemble à gagner il
faut aussi ce qui va à non qui tombe non
attention quand même un peut-être foulée
3 way to b 3 6 6 et encore mais à 4 way
le pion à qui est fort aussi un bon
attention paroisse ici à matt en a mais
ça va et maintenant le pion roubaix roi
fuite pourquoi prendre foot et 5 a bien
joué il ya enfin ce qui fait jouer six
tours b troyes et tours b 1
parce que ça suffit pourquoi il n'a pas
joué tomber trop est tombé 1
j'ai pas mais en tout cas ils gagnent
autant et il finit le match s'est
terminé là il ya il a quoi il a + b + 3
rs 3 40 c'est fini victoire de maxime
etienne bat est content mais t'as vu
comme ils étaient concentrés pour pour
ce dernier mois il s'est bien remis dans
le bullet il s'est bien mis dans la tête
on est d'accord mais alors il est où
concentré quoi parce que peut-être qui
tous au max de l'armée selon max tu sais
il regarde pas toujours le temps qui
reste
il est peut-être pas au courant qu'il a
juste gagné deux matches encore cfa
voire la présence d'esprit d'aller jeter
un oeil était bien concentré tu
continues à à jouer à fond mais antoine
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est gagné il a toujours su ouais non
non la cct reçues il a toujours su amène
en mai il a sorti la petite rond paula
il sait que c'est gagné je sens une
autre contre 2,15 abbaoui l' iran un
petit hommage quand même ils sont
arrivés un communiqué c'est la dédicace
super au blitz ayant plus il est bien la
version c'est ça la fou prend effet ce 4
ses gammes
le carnet secret ah oui qui vit l'armée
a annoncé 5 à 0 2 c'est pas car c'est
pas tant la sais pas car je calque le
car avait assez terrible ça va il peut
le faire quand même pas si on espère
qu'il va pas du tout le carnet là c'est
horrible ouais voilà la voilà ils sont
fous
bah oui mes carnets quand même dray
c'est dommage bon il a fait la petite
dédicace kevin est le prix d'une partie
etienne le prix d'une partie et ben là
il vaut pas grand chose sur celle là
cette partie ne vont pas grand-chose
kevin
or mme adjiman balech j'ai gagné bah
ouais mais après c'est normal
et puis il faut décompresser ça fait
quelques-uns en a qui jouent les bacs
ces troisièmes qu'ils s'en pose
quasiment après je pense qu'on n'est pas
bien sûr hein quoi qu'il en soit on
n'est pas très sûr qu'il soit plus fort
mais contre malgré qu'il ait la
meilleure connexion de paris ni du
tournoi contre manu sera joué un peu
mieux que ça
ouais et puis faut donc la connexion
importante aussi quand même oui
non mais il peut il peut il peut battre
magnus à un adversaire qui lui réussit
pas si mal en finale au final en blitz
mais bon on me la joues hemingway pas
s'il gagne contre artemiev demain 14h
assez peu clair un à 14h en plus alors
tenir qui va pas jouer à 2 heures du
matin ah bah oui c'est correct tout cas
là la trompe offs qui sait peut-être
qu'il aurait dû sortir depuis le début
en la dame derna match 5 sa part bon ba
hmad ont trouvé aucun sens si ce d'après
ça se passe et cela cela je pense que
hanoi h 14 regarde le jeu car il a
acheté à travers un programme pour en
comprendre tous reproches quatre ans
mais ça va oui échange des dames et là
il ya eu 6 ouais bon champion il va
manger aussi combien tôt voilà là le
sage ou quand même un petit peu d'argent
annoncé parti etienne
pourquoi ce jour parce qu'il ya une
partie du prize pool qui à la
qualification et notre prorata des gars
et des parties gagnées dans le match
peut-être 40,50 dollars tu as mais 40,50
dollars sur le carnet ça fait plaisir
prépa carnet un abat les prépas carnet
ont la valeur qu'elles ont un taux à cut
pro oui il ya beaucoup de pions chez
maxim mais un problème de connexion vous
là des coups mais maintenant il peut il
peut être des coups c'est pas grave au
meilleur des moments j'ai envie de dire
ouais ouais elle fait plaisir sa déco ça
l'a fait plaisir
salah a fait saisir
après il suit un peu un sur celle-là oui
mais bon perdre
il a l'air d'être en retard au h4 marc
loranger 4,7
[Musique]
enfin c'est pas grave
est-ce qu'il restait encore du temps
dans le match non alors maxime qui la
joue encore un peu psy va vouloir au
tours fc
mais ça doit bien ça suffit pas mais ça
gagnait ça gagne quelques secondes qui
aurait pu être précieuse attend ça
suffit pas puisque ça commence à se
faire que si s'agisse way achats tous
manqués est-ce qu'il est manque un tempo
ouais ouais ouais je lis c'est seoung
saison guy et c'est gagné etienne ça y
est c'est officiel
maxime est qualifiée ifil en demies où
il rencontrera le vainqueur du match
karl scène artemiev demain 14h bac une
impression le coach lui un coach heureux
bascou
comme prévu il y avait de la marge sur
le sur le match après après malgré way
malgré l'autre choc malgré les les
décors en fait quand maxime il en forme
il est tellement fort que voilà ça joue
le top top mondial quoi est ce qu'on
s'en verrait pas une arena dekra quito
ou pas août est claqué way attend
peut-être que maxime va faire une envoyé
des petits trucs mais sa façon sa 22e si
je fais le switch de stream c'est
maintenant ouais ça s'agite pour que
maxime vient d'envoyer des baies ap il
faut forger de frime
ah oui d'accord c'est pour ça que je dis
est ce qu'on risque on part en aréna
dekra quito allez allez j'en vois avec
je mets quoi je mets un peu des clips ou
pas bon j'en vois et puis après on
réfléchit plus que je vous propose c'est
que j'envoie il faut que tu peux que tu
lances le ton annoncé sa belle ouvrage
de mai à 22h mais déjà faut que je
change le crime
donc j'en vois ok donc ne bougeait pas
les gars etienne toi t'as rien à faire
les gars gens voient leur aide dans
quelques secondes
on revient tout de suite